THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
ATKINS BATES BACKER GEORGES
BRADFORD CABALLERO CORTESE
DALLY GOD TO RAZA EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ ROSE HERTZBERG HUESO
HURTADO JONES KAMLAGER BLARED
LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN BUT CHAO OF BOTH.
PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER AMBERG WHAT KASKY
WIENER WELL. MEMBERS OF A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WHAT THE
MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
GLAZERS AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR RUBIO. GOOD
MORNING. GRACIOUS AND MERCIFUL
GOD. IN THIS SEASON OF
REFRESHMENT AND RENEWAL. AND IN
THESE DAYS OF SOLIDARITY WITH
THE JEWISH PEOPLE WHO OBSERVE
YOM HA SHOAH HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY WE PRAY. WE
PRAY THAT NEW HOPE MAY RISE
FROM HUMAN DISCOURAGEMENT. THE
NEW FACE MAY RISE FROM HUMAN
DOUBT. THE NEW LOVE MAY RISE
FROM HUMAN INDIFFERENCE. THE
NEW COURAGE MAY RISE FROM HUMAN
TIMIDITY. AND THAT NEW CHILE
MAY RISE FROM HUMAN SORROWS.
BLESS US FOR THE TASKS THAT LIE
BEFORE US THIS DAY. THAT
THROUGH OUR EFFORTS. OTHERS MAY
COME TO EXPERIENCE LIBERATION.
FROM HATE FROM OPPRESSION
CONFINEMENT OF ANY KIND WE ASK
THIS IN YOUR NAME COMMENT.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE
SENATORS SENATORS LEAN ONE AND
STERN PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO AA WILL BE WAIVED FOR
THE JOINT HEARING OF THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEES TO MEET
AND DISCUSS THE OSTEOPATHIC
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
WITHOUT FOUR DAYS NOTICE IN THE
DAILY FILE. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
FILE PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
SEVEN OH SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
SIX OH NINE WITH AMENDMENTS
SIXTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS TO
FIFTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS THREE
FORTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
FIVE OH SEVEN NUMBERS
MILLISECOND READING FILE WILL
BE DEEMED READ MOVING ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS WE'RE
GONNA TAKE UP. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT. SENATOR BATES
WE'RE GOING TO- ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. THANK YOU MA'AM
OUR PRESIDENT OF FILE ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DEAN CROWDEN
AND KELLY'S NAY GOD TO THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS MISTER GRODEN S.
ZERO OF LESSON LASSEN COUNTY MR
**** IS CHEAP PROBATION OFFICER
OF KINGS COUNTY BOTH APPOINTEES
WERE APPROVED BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH TWENTY
FOURTH ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I JUST
WANNA RISE AND SAY- I DO NOTE
THAT DEAN GROUND A PERSONALLY
HE'S THE SHERIFF IN LASSEN
COUNTY WE ALSO OF THE HIGH
DESERT STATE PRISON THERE-
WHO'S WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
A I STRONGLY RECOMMEND HIS
APPROVAL. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THESE APPOINTMENTS.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS THE DISTRICT. BATES HI
BAKER HI FORGES HI BRADFORD HI
BY ADAM HI CORTESE HI DALLY I
DODD. DURAZO HI EGGMAN. HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES FIVE KAMLAGER. K.
LAYERED HI LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION. FIVE
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN HI A TOTAL OF
BOTH. HI PAM HI PORTANTINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. HI
I'M BURKE FIVE WACO SKI HI
WIENER FIVE WILK FIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS.
OKAY FIRST VEHICLE DODD. GROWTH
I KAMLAGER. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS I. DODD
KAMLAGER. HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENTS ARE
CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY NINE. SENATOR
BATES- ITEM TWENTY NINE ISN'T
THE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
ROCCO DAVIS AND MICHELLE
MARTINEZ TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION MISTER DAVIS IS VICE
PRESIDENT AND REGIONAL MANAGER
FOR THE LABORERS INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF NORTH AMERICA MISS
MARTINEZ IS THE FOUNDER OF
EMERGENT P. FOR ADVISORS AND
PREVIOUSLY SERVED FOR TWELVE
YEARS ON THE SANTA ANA CITY
COUNCIL BOTH APPOINTEES WERE
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MARCHTWENTY FOUR
ONE FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THESE APPOINTMENTS.
NEWMAN SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU MA'AM PRESENT RIGHT I HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING BOTH
MISTER DAVIS AND MISS MARTINEZ
THEY WILL BOTH MAKE EXCELLENT
COMMISSIONERS- AND I STRONGLY
URGE THEIR APPROVAL. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS HI BASS HI BAKER. HI
PORGES HI BRADFORD HI CABALLERO
HI FOR TESTING HI DALLY HI DON.
HI THE RAZA HI EGGMANHI GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI HER TADO
I JONES. FIVE KAMLAGER HI
LAYERED HI LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE.
HI MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF
THE- I CAN. HI PORTANTINO FIVE
ROTH. HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
NUMBER FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI.
FIVE WIENER HI WILK PLEASE I.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN HI. HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS ZERO THE APPOINTMENTS ARE
CONFIRMED. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE SENATOR
RUBIO ARE YOU PREPARED SHE IS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE THREE
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ELEVEN BY SENATOR RUBIO
RELATIVE TO THE CANCER PATIENTS
BILL OF RIGHTS SENATOR RUBIO-THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE. TODAY
I RISE TO PRESENT S. C. R.
ELEVEN THE CANCER PATIENT BILL
OF RIGHTS. MEMBERS WE HAVE ALL
BEEN TOUCHED BY CANCER IN ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER THROUGH
FRIENDS FAMILIES OUR OWN
CONSTITUENTS. FOR ME TODAY I
THINK OF GRACE Q. FROM WEST
COVINA. SOMEONE WHO I GOT TO
KNOW WELL AS WE WALK. IN OUR
OWN COMMUNITY AT RELAY FOR
LIFE. SHE WAS SO INVOLVED IN
VERY COMMITTED TO THE CALLS AND
WHO LOST HER LIFE THIS WEEK TO
CANCER. CRAZIEST EXPERIENCE TO
BECOME A STRONG ADVOCATE NOT
VOLUNTEER WITH THE AMERICAN
CANCER SOCIETY BUT TOO OFTEN.
CANCER PATIENTS LIKE GRACE
STRUGGLE TO ACCESS THE BEST
TREATMENTS AND CURES MADE
POSSIBLE BY ADVANCES IN CANCER
SCIENCE. IN THE THANK YOU
VALLEY WE ARE EXTREMELY LUCKY
TO HAVE CITY OF HOLES IN OUR
BACKYARD. CYDIA HOPE AND OTHER
CANCER RESEARCH CENTERS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY CONDUCTING CUTTING
EDGE RESEARCH TESTING CLINICAL
TRIALS TO DEVELOP NEW
TREATMENTS AND CURES.
UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY CANCER
PATIENTS ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
STRUGGLE TO ACCESS THOSE
LIFESAVING MIRACLES THE BEST
CHANCE OF THE CURE IS THE FIRST
CHANCE OF UP HERE. THAT IS WHY
I HAVE CO AUTHORED THE- RIGHT
OFF THE CANCER PATIENT BILL OF
RIGHTS TO DECLARE THAT CANCER
PATIENTS DESERVE INFORMATION
ABOUT TREATMENT OPTIONS AT
TIMELY ACCESS TO CANCER CARE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THIS IMPORTANT CANCER PATIENTS
BILL OF RIGHTS RESOLUTION THANK
YOU. SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF A C. R.
ELEVEN- AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE SINK EVER VALLEY MENTIONED-
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITIES IN CANCER OUTCOMES
ACCESS TO- CANCER TRIALS-
TREATMENT- AND THIS RESOLUTION
HIGHLIGHTS THOSE DIFFERENCES
AND CALLS ON A CANCER PATIENT
BILL OF RIGHTS ACCESS TO THE
BEST- AND HOSPITALS IN THE MOST
WELL TRAINED DOCTORS SHOULD NOT
BE LIMITED TO CERTAIN PEOPLE-
SO I RISE AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR
AND OBVIOUSLY THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF CITY OF HOPE-
OF WHICH I SHARE WITH- MY
SENATE COLLEAGUES FROM SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY. ANY SIX
STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT FOR S. C.
R. ELEVEN. SENATOR BAKER. GOOD
MORNING PHIL MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR
ELEVEN IN TWENTY SIXTEEN I WAS
EXCITED AND HONORED TO BE
RUNNING FOR STATE ASSEMBLY MY
FATHER WAS DIAGNOSED WITH BRAIN
CANCER. I IMMEDIATELY SHUT DOWN
THE CAMPAIGN TO FOCUS ON HIS
CARE AND TO BE WITH HIM AND MY
MOTHER. AND I DUG THROUGH THE
COMPLICATED AND RAPIDLY
ADVANCING. WORLD OF MODERN
CANCER CARE SCARING FOR
CLINICAL TRIALS THAT MIGHT HELP
HIM. I BEGAN TO LEARN ABOUT
IMMUNOTHERAPY GENETIC
SEQUENCING AND INTEGRATED
CANCER CARE MANY THINGS THAT
WERE NOT STANDARD OF CARE AT
THE TIME. WITHOUT A LAB IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE GET A
FULL GENOME AND EXOME SCREENING.
RATHER INEXPENSIVELY AND THEN
LITERALLY FOUGHT WITH OUR BRAIN
SURGEON ABOUT ACCESS TO THE
TISSUE SAMPLES. WE ENDED UP
EVENTUALLY PURSUING SIMILAR
LIMITED SEQUENCING AND WE
PURSUED A RATHER NOVEL APPROACH
AND MY FATHER WAS ACTUALLY
HAVING QUITE A BIT OF SUCCESS
IN HIS BATTLE WITH CANCER WHEN
HE EVENTUALLY DIED FROM A BLOOD
CLOT. THESE ADVANCES HAVE
GOTTEN MORE ORE PROMISING. AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
SENSIBLE. A FRIEND PASSED AWAY
RECENTLY ATTENDED AND JOURNAL
MEMORY FOR A FOR FROM CANCER.
HE WAS A VET AND HE THOUGHT HE
COULDN'T GET THE INNOVATIVE
CARE THAT HE WANTED AT THE VA
AND SO WE TURN TO GO FUND ME.
WHICH IS A PLACE TO OFTEN NOW
THAT IS WHERE PEOPLE GO TO FIND
THAT MEDICAL CARE IN OUR
COUNTRY. SIR BELIEVE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THESE CUTTING EDGE
THERAPIES ARE ACCESSIBLE. AND
UNDERSTANDABLE TO EVERYONE IN
THE STATE. BUT NOT JUST THE
WEALTHY. SOME PROUD TO CO
AUTHOR THIS BILL I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN
PARK FOR PUTTING THIS FORWARD
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR JONES. PRESIDENT
AND- SENATORS I RISE TODAY AS A
CANCER SURVIVOR MYSELF- IN
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. ELEVEN. ON
A COLD RAINY DAY I'M JUST IN
DECEMBER OF NINETEEN NINETY
NINE. I HEARD THE THREE MOST
SCARIEST WORDS IN THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE. YOU HAVE CANCER. I
WAS THIRTY ONE YEARS OLD. MY
WIFE WAS TWENTY EIGHT MY
YOUNGEST SON WAS SIX MONTHS OLD
MY DAUGHTER WAS TWO AND MY
OLDEST SON WAS FOUR YEARS OLD.
LET THAT DOCTOR'S OFFICE IN THE
RAINSTORM AND SAT IN MY CAR FOR
A COUPLE OF MOMENTS TRYING TO
CATCH MY BREATH. AT THIRTY ONE
YEARS OLD. YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE TOLD YOU HAVE CANCER.
WELL FORTUNATELY FOR ME I HAD
ONE OF THE EASIEST CANCERS TO
TREAT AND TO CURE AND TO
SURVIVE FROM BUT NOT EVERYBODY.
HAS THAT SAME DIAGNOSIS. BUT AS
I SAT IN MY CAR I DIDN'T THINK
ABOUT MYSELF- SO MUCH. HI AS MY
FAITH IN CHRIST- TOLD ME THAT I
HAD A PROMISE AND HAVEN'T IF
THIS TURNS TO THE WORSE. BUT I
DIDN'T THINK ABOUT MY YOUNG
WIFE. MY THREE YOUNG CHILDREN.
AND- THAT'S A HEAVY BURDEN ON A
PERSON TO ENTER. CANCER HAS
TOUCHED MY FAMILY IN MANY OTHER
WAYS MY WIFE'S MOTHER AND IS
SURVIVING ESOPHAGEAL CANCER.
THANKS TO A BRILLIANT SURGEON
AT USC MEDICAL CENTER. MY MOM'S
DAD DIED OF ESOPHAGEAL CANCER
OVER FIFTY YEARS AGO WHEN THE
WEATHER IS TREATABLE AS IT IS
TODAY. THIS RESOLUTION IS VERY
IMPORTANT. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. HI- MY- THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS AND WELL WISHES FOR
THOSE THAT ARE DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER CONTINUE. AND HOPEFULLY
THAT MY STORY CAN BE AN
ENCOURAGEMENT TO THOSE TO KEEP
FIGHTING. AND DO EVERYTHING YOU
CAN TO LIVE NOT JUST FOR
YOURSELF. YOUR FAMILY THAT LOVE
YOU AND SUPPORT YOU. AYE ASPEN
AYE VOTE ON A C. R. ELEVEN
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SENATOR RUBIO YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR SHARING THEIR
PERSONAL STORIES OTHER
IMPORTANT TAKE HERE AND TO ALL
THE CANCER PATIENTS OUT THERE
WE STAND WITH YOU AND THE FIGHT
FOR A CURE AND WITH THAT
POLITICS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATORS RESOLUTION IS ELIGIBLE
FOR YOU UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION. SAYING
NINE EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTD.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FIVE SENATOR
UMBERG ARE YOU PREPARED HE IS
PLEASE RECALL HELLO PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR UMBERG
RELATIVE TO COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION WEEK SENATE A
SENATOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT S. C. R. TWENTY TWO
RESOLUTION THAT PROCLAIMS.
APRIL FIVE THROUGH APRIL NINTH
OF THIS YEAR AS COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION WEEK OR C. D. F. I.
WEEK OF THE LAST FIFTY YEARS
CDFI IS A BEEN THE MECHANISM
FOR COMMUNITY DRIVEN PROGRESS
CDFI IS A MISSION DRIVEN
FINANCIAL INTERMEDIARIES THE
FOCUS ON COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
BY LEVERAGING PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE FUNDS THEY DELIVER
AFFORDABLE FINANCIAL SERVICES
TO COMMUNITIES IN NEED WHETHER
IT BE FINANCING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NONPROFITS STRUGGLING
SMALL BUSINESSES CD TO CD OF
EYES HAVE SERVED OUR FINANCIAL
FIRST RESPONDERS. AS OUR
FINANCIAL FIRST RESPONDERS BY
DELIVERING AFFORDABLE IN
RESPONSIBLE LENDING TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT IS CONSISTENTLY
RELIED UPON CDFI IS TO PARTNER
WITH US ON MEETING OUR MOST
PRESSING ISSUES AND SIGNIFIES
HAVE EXCEEDED EXPECTATIONS.
THROUGH OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
CDFI IS. AT THE GOLDEN STATE
ACQUISITION FUND CDFI IS A WORK
COLLECTIVELY TO FUND NINETY
SEVEN PROJECTS DELIVERING
THOUSANDS OF UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
CALIFORNIANS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
RESOLUTION. SEEING NONE OF.
SEEING NONE THIS IS- THIS
RESOLUTION IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IT IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SEEING NINE FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY SEVEN
SENATOR MAN. ARE YOU PREPARED
HE IS PLEASE READ. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS SENATOR IF YOU COULD
JUST WAIT A SECOND WE'RE GOING
TO READ IT FIRST. SENATE
RESOLUTION TWENTY TWO BY
SENATOR MEN RELATIVE TO NOTICE.
NOW SENATOR MEN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
THE MORNING MEMBER SORRY FOR
JUMPING THE GUN. I'M HONORED
THIS RISE TO SPEAK IN
RECOGNITION OF SR TWENTY TWO
COMMEMORATING NO RUSE. NO ROSE
CAN BE BROKEN DOWN AND
TRANSLATED INTO TWO WORDS
MEANING NEW DAY. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE MILLIONS OF
IRANIAN AMERICANS AND OTHERS
WHO OBSERVE THIS DAY EACH YEAR
AT THE VERNAL EQUINOX.
CELEBRATION FOCUSES ON THE
REBIRTH AND RENEWAL THAT COMES
WITH THE PASSING OF ANOTHER
YEAR. IT BEGINS AT THE FIRST
DAY OF SPRING IS WIDELY ENJOYED
THROUGH A VARIETY OF ACTIVITIES
THAT REFLECT THE FRESH
BEGINNINGS OF THE NEW YEAR- AND
SO THERE'S THE JUMPING OF FIRE
ON THE TUESDAY BEFORE THE EQUAL
KNOCKS. THE SHAKING OF THE
HOUSE OR HOUSE CLEANING THAT'S
MEANT TO WASH AWAY THE PREVIOUS
YEAR. AND NO RUSE AT ITS HEART
IS ABOUT BRINGING TOGETHER THE
IDEALS OF PEACE RESPECT UNITY
AND THE SHARED GOAL OF A
FRUITFUL NEW YEAR. THIS NEW
YEAR'S CELEBRATION CONNECTS
PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT ETHNICITIES
AND RELIGIONS FROM ACROSS THE
WORLD. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE AND EXPRESS MY DEEP
THANKS TO OUR ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY THE FIRST IRANIAN
AMERICAN ELECTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
AND YOU MAY BE ENJOYING THE
CANDLES THAT HE THOUGHTFULLY
DISTRIBUTED TO ALL OF US TO
COMMEMORATE NO RUSE. I'M
ESPECIALLY HONORED TO RECOGNIZE
NO RICH THIS YEAR DOES AS AN
EXAMPLE. OF HOW WE CAN ALL COME
TOGETHER TO REBUILD. BETTER AND
REDEDICATE OURSELVES TO
STANDING TOGETHER IN SOLIDARITY
WITH EACH OTHER MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU. IS TERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
RESOLUTION. SAYING NINE MEMBERS
THIS RESOLUTION IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SEEING NONE IS THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY THREE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. ARE YOU
PREPARED. HE IS PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACTUAL
LEADING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW. I CAN'T
COUNT THE NUMBER OF BILLS THAT
WE HAVE- DISCUSSED IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT OVER THE YEARS
DEALING WITH RENEWABLE ENERGY
PARTICULARLY SOLAR ENERGY. ONE
OF THOSE AREAS OF PUBLIC POLICY
THAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED WITH
RESPECT TO SOLAR IS INFORMED BY
PROPOSITION SEVEN THAT WAS
PASSED BY THE VOTERS IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY WHICH EXEMPTED.
NEW NEWLY CONSTRUCTION ON THE
DEFINITION OF PROPERTY TAX FOR
PURPOSES OF SOLAR. FEDERAL TAX
LAW IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
CREATED INVESTMENT TAX
STRUCTURE. THAT CREATED WHAT'S
CALLED THE PARTNERSHIP FLIP. IN
THESE CLIPS BASICALLY ALLOW
INVESTORS TO GET THE TAX
BENEFITS UNTIL THEY HIT A
CERTAIN NUMBER AND THEN
TRANSFER OF OWNERSHIP THESE ARE
TRANSACTIONS THAT ARE AND
FORMER THE VERY OUTSET OF THE
RELATIONSHIP TO DEAL WITH THE
TAX STRUCTURE TO DEAL WITH THE
EXEMPTIONS AND THE LIKE THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION HAS
CAUSED SOME CONFUSION BY
PRODUCING. CERTAIN GUIDELINES
THAT PROVIDE CONTRADICTORY
DIRECTION BUT THE CHANGE OF
OWNESHIP WOULD OCCUR IF THERE
WAS MORE THAN 50% BUT- CHANGE
OF THAT OWNERSHIP. SO THIS
MEASURE TO GIVE CLARITY AND
CONFIDENCE TO THE ROBUST SOLAR
MARKET THAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING
IN CALIFORNIA AVOIDS THAT
CONFUSION AND COULDN'T GET
HOPEFULLY INSPIRES THE- THE
FOLKS TO CONTINUE TO INVEST TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON INVESTMENT IN
SOLAR ASK YOUR- VOTE THANK YOU.
SAN DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I IF I COULD I HAVE A
QUESTION OF OFFER SCREEN TO THE
TICKET QUESTION CERTAINLY. TO
THE CHAIR YEAH SO- BUT MY
QUESTION IS- SOLAR SYSTEMS DO
NOT IT PAY LOCAL COUNTY TAXES
AND SO WITH THIS- THEN IT UP-
AND SECURE ROLE SO THOUGH THOSE
TAXES TYPICALLY GO. TO THE
COUNTIES IN THE AREAS WHERE
THESE SYSTEMS ARE BUILT AND
THOSE ARE TAXES THAT HELP- FIND
LAW ENFORCEMENT- JUVENILE
JUSTICE ALL THOSE THINGS THAT-
COUNTIES PROVIDE AND THERE HAS
BEEN EXEMPTION SO WHEN THIS
CHANGES- OVER DOES THAT DOES
THAT MONEY GO TO THE COUNTIES
OR TO GO BACK TO THE INVESTORS-
WHICH WE CAN GIVE ME SOME
CLARIFICATION ON. WHAT HAPPENS
HERE YES CERTAINLY. WELL TO THE
CHAIR RIGHT NOW SINCE THE
VOTERS PASSED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY THIS- EXCLUSION OF
ADDITIONAL ACTIVITY IN THE
SOLAR SYSTEM FOR NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED. DEFINITION FROM
PROPERTY TAX THAT THAT'S THAT'S
BEEN THE RULE FOR SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY. THIS IS ONLY
THIS QUESTION ABOUT HOW OLD THE
CONSTRUCT OF TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THE- FEDERAL INVESTOR TAX
CREDIT. HAS BEEN FORMED THROUGH
THESE TRANSACTIONS. AND SO THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION IS
CHANGING THAT SO THERE'S NO
ISSUE ABOUT DOLLARS THAT HAVE
BEEN FLOWING. TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS UNDER THE
PROPERTY TAX DISTRIBUTION AT
ALL THE ONLY QUESTION IS WILL
THAT CHANGE GOING FORWARD.
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO ADOPT
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION'S
GUIDELINES AND INTERPRETATION.
AND WHAT WE'RE SAYING HERE IS
THAT THE PEOPLE THE CITY
CALIFORNIA AND THIS LEGISLATURE
IS TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
PRIORITIZE RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
THIS AND WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE THOSE INSTRUMENTS
OF GOVERNMENT ARE ACTING
CONSISTENT WITH OUR INTENT AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THE PEOPLE. AND IT SHOULDN'T
AFFECT A NICKEL TO ANYBODY.
EXCEPT INCREASE MORE INVESTMENT
MORE RATE OF RETURN AND MORE
SOLAR ENERGY. BEING PRODUCED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE SENATOR
HERTZBERG- SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR CORKTOWN- THE
LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY IS BEEN.
PASSING A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
CONSTITUTE FOR EXAMPLE LET'S
SAY- PROPERTY TRANSFERS FROM-
REASSESSMENT AND I THINK THE
CONCERN HERE IS WE'VE WE'RE
EXPANDING IT TO FINANCIAL
TRANSACTIONS IF I'M READING
THIS CORRECTLY WHICH- KIND OF
REPLICATE SIDE THE INFAMOUS
DALE SITUATION- WITH THE HOTEL
IN- LOS ANGELES WHERE THE
COUNTY LOST ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROPERTY TAX BECAUSE
THEY STRUCTURE THE TRANSACTION.
SO THAT NO ONE ON MORE THAN 50%
OF TE- PROPERTY WAS OWNED
COULD YOU EXPLAIN HOW THIS IS
NOT LIKE THAT BECAUSE THE
FINANCIAL TRANSACTION THAT WERE
SPEAKING OF IN THIS BILL
ACTUALLY IS ADDING PEOPLE SO NO
ONE OWNS YOU KNOW MORE THAN 50%
AND I THINK THAT'S THE WE DON'T
LIKE TO CALL IT A LOOPHOLE WE
LIKE TO CALL IT A- AND M.
MISINTERPRETATION. OF WHAT OF
WHAT CONSTITUTES A CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP SO A LITTLE MORE
EXPLANATION ON THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR OUR LEGISLATURES
TAKING A POSITION TO ACTUALLY
EXAMS FINANCIAL TRANSACTIONS
THAT SHOULD BE COUNTED. AS
CHANGE OF OWNERSHIPS. THAT
COULD BE HAPPENING AT SIX AND-
COMPLETELY. OPPOSED IN THE
MICHAEL DELL SITUATION THE
HOTEL OF THE TO THE CORNER OF
WILSHIRE BOULEVARD AND- OCEAN
IN SANTA MONICA WAS OWNED BY
PERSON A- THEY HELD IT IN THE
CORPORATION. BOTH THE BUILDING
AND THE LAND WAS HELD IN THE
CORPORATION WHEN MICHAEL DELL
PER PURCHASE THAT PROPERTY HE
PURCHASED THE CORPORATION A
100% OF THE CORPORATION AND SO
THE PROPERTY WAS NOT REASSESSED
IN THAT TRANSACTION BECAUSE
THAT WAS NO TRANSFER OF THE
REAL ESTATE IN THAT LOOPHOLE
JUST THE TRANSFER OF THE
CORPORATE SHARES. THAT HAPPENS
SUBSEQUENT IN TIME. THIS
TRANSACTION IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT. ON THE DAY YOU ENTER
INTO TRANCE. FIRST IT'S
INFORMED BY PROPOSITIONS SEVEN
THAT WAS PASSED BY THE PEOPLE.
SO THAT THEY CREATED THE
EXEMPTION ALREADY EXISTED. THE
NATURE OF THE DISCUSSION IS THE
PARTNERSHIP FLIP WHEN YOU PUT
THE MONEY DOWN HAPPENS ON DAY
ONE IT WASN'T A SUBSEQUENT
TRANSACTION AND ON DAY ONE IT'S
JUST FACILITATES THE ABILITY
FOR THE PARTIES TO GET THE
BENEFIT OF A ROBUST INVESTMENT
ON THE ONE HAND YET FULLY ENJOY
THE BENEFITS OF THE TAXES. THAT
HELP INFORM AND REDUCE THE
PRICE AND COST OF THE
PARTICULAR TRANSACTION SO IT
REALLY IS NOT COMPARE OF ALL AT
ALL ONE IS HAS TO DO WITH THE
REAL ESTATE TRANSACTION THIS
HAS TO DO WITH A VOTE OF THE
PEOPLE AND ACTIVISTS ALREADY
BEEN DETERMINED AND ALL WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE. IS TO AVOID
THE CONFUSION IN THE MARKET
PLACE CAUSE BY THE BOARDOF
EQUALIZATION PROVIDING COUNTRY
GUIDELINES FOR THE FIRST TIME
RECENTLY OUR IN COUNTRYTO THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT AND COUNTRY
TO THE VOTE OF THE PEOPLE
DIAMETRICALLY OPPOSED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
THAT YOUR CLOSER WOULD YOU LIKE
THAT'S IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS HI BATES.
BAKER. HI PORGES. I BRADFORD.
FIVE CABALLERO HIGH COURT TODAY
HI DALLY. NO DODD. HI TO RAZA.
I EGGMAN. HI GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ HI GROSS. HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO HI HER TADO. JONES HI
KAMLAGER HI LAYERED. I LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ. MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN I A CHIRLA
BOTH I CAN HI PORTANTINO HI
ROTH. HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
NUMBER ALL RIGHT HI WHITE HOUSE
SKI. HI WIENER HI WELL. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
NO GROWTH HI HER TADO. MELENDEZ
WILK. HIGHS THIRTY THREE KNOWS
TO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT
SENATOR WIENER HE IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION AT TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR WIENER RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY SENATOR WIENER THE FLOOR'S
YOURS I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS- TO PRESENT- SCR TWENTY
NINE- TODAY IS YOM HA SHOAH
WHICH IS ISRAEL'S HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY. WHICH IS
WIDELY RECOGNIZED BY JEWS AND
ALLIES AROUND THE WORLD ON
SUNDAY. PRESIDENT BIDEN
DECLARED APRIL FOURTH THRILLED.
OF OVER OF OBSERVE OF THE DAY
EVERY OF VICTIMS OF THE
HOLOCAUST AND WE'RE POISED TO
DECLARE TODAY CALIFORNIA'S
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY- DUE TO
COVE IT IT'S BEEN TWO YEARS
SINCE THE JEWISH CAUCUS LAST
OBSERVE HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE
DAY. IN THE CAPITAL IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE WERE BLESSED TO
HAVE TEN HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS
ARE SHARING THEIR STORIES HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. BUT WE TYPICALLY
BRING SURVIVORS UP TO
SACRAMENTO EVERY YEAR FOR TWO
REASONS- TO HONOR THEIR LEGACY
AND THE SACRIFICE THE SACRIFICE
OF THOSE WE LOST AND BECAUSE
THEY SERVE AS A LIVING REMINDER
OF THE IMPACT OF WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE LET BIGOTRY GO
UNCHECKED. WHEN SURVIVORS SHARE
THEIR HEART WRENCHING STORIES
THEY OPEN THE MOST INTIMATE
WINDOW INTO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE DON'T SPEAK OUT AGAINST HATE
AND BIGOTRY THESE ARE STORIES
THAT ANYONE OF CONSCIENCE
CANNOT IGNORE. OVER QUICKLY
LOSING THE FINAL GENERATION OF
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS- INDEED
COVERT NINETEEN TRAGICALLY HAS
BEEN ESPECIALLY DEVASTATING IN
TWENTY TWENTY COVER NINETEEN
TOOK THE LIVES OF NINE HUNDRED
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS. LIVING IN
ISRAEL ALONE WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY AROUND THE WORLD THAT'S
WHY WE BELIEVE THAT
OPPORTUNITIES TO HEAR FROM
SURVIVORS IS SO VITAL WE NEED
TO BE THE BEARERS OF THEIR
STORIES WHEN THEY'RE NO LONGER.
AROUND TO TELL THOSE STORIES.
SADLY HOLIC IGN IS GROWING AT.
RATES WITH TWO THIRDS OF
AMERICAN MILLENNIALS UNABLE TO
IDENTIFY WHAT ELSE THAT'S IS. A
NEARLY A QUARTER UNSURE IF THEY
HAVE EVEN HEARD ABOUT THE
HOLOCAUST. AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
HOLOCAUST DENIALISM IS GROWING
WITHIN THE INFORMATION VACUUM
AND SO TOO IS WHITE SUPREMACY.
IN FACT OUR HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY CEREMONY IN
THIS BUILDING TWO YEARS AGO
TOOK PLACE JUST TWO DAYS AFTER
THE SHOOTING AT THE HOMEPOD
SYNAGOGUE. IN AND PULL AWAY AND
SO MONTHS THE DAY. AFTER THE
COULD. SENATE MASS. IT WAS AND
SOBERING REMINDER. THAT THE
LESSONS OF THE HOLOCAUST ARE
EVER PRESENT TODAY. SINCE THEN
WE HAVE MEANT THAT WE HAVE
WITNESSED MORE MURDEROUS
ATTACKS ON AMERICAN JEWS IN
JERSEY CITY- AND MANZI. I WITH
RECORD LEVELS OF ANTI SEMITIC
ATTACKS NATIONWIDE. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT HATRED IS NEVER
ISOLATED TO ONE GROUP. TESTIS
COUNTLESS LGBTQ PEOPLE PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES- ROMA AND
SINTI PEOPLE WERE ALSO MURDERED
BY THE **** ALONG SIDE SIX
MILLION JEWS. WE HAVE SEEN
SIMILAR SPIKES IN WHITE
SUPREMACIST AND HATE MOTIVATED
VIOLENCE TARGETING COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS MUSLIMS AND
LGBTQ PEOPLE AND OUR COUNTRY IN
RECENT YEARS. I'M PERHAPS MOST
PRESENT OF MINE FOR MANY OF US
A YEAR'S WORTH OF HARMFUL
LANGUAGE FROM OUR HIGHEST
LEADERS ON DOWN HAS INCITED A
SIGNIFICANT RISE IN VICIOUS
ATTACKS TARGETING. THE ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY. UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO
COVERED PROTOCOLS- WE ONCE
AGAIN CANNOT HAVE HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS WITH US THIS YEAR.
INSTEAD WE ARE MAKING AN EFFORT
TO PERSONALIZE TODAY'S CEREMONY
IN A DIFFERENT WAY COLLEAGUES-
WE HAVE PROVIDED EACH OF YOU
WITH A PRINTED TWEET FROM THE
OFFICIAL ELSE FITS MEMORIAL
TWITTER PAGE AND IF YOU'RE NOT
FOLLOWING UP PAGE. YOU SHOULD-
WHICH HELPS TO PRESERVE THE MAN
MARIE OF THE MORE THAN POINT
ONE MILLION PEOPLE. WHO WERE
EXTERMINATED AND ALICE FITS
BIRKENAU CAMP. IF YOU HAVEN'T
GRABBED IT ALREADY YOUR FRAMES
PHOTO OF THAT TWEET IS WAITING
FOR YOU AT THE TABLE ACROSS
FROM THE MIGHTY MOUNTAINS. AS
YOU'LL NOTICE THE TWEET TELLS
THE STORY OF A VICTIM OF THE
HOLOCAUST WHO SHARES YOUR
BIRTHDAY. A SMALL WINDOW INTO
THE DEVASTATION THAT IS OFTEN
DIFFICULT TO COMPREHEND.
REPRESENTING EACH OF OUR
BIRTHDAYS COLLEAGUES AS YOU
LOOK AT THE PICTURES OF THOSE
WHO LOOK WHO WE LOST PLEASE
ALSO JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING A C.
R. TWENTY NINE TO HONOR ND
REMEMBER ALL OF THE HOLOCAUST
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS AND TO
USE THE LESSONS OF THE
HOLOCAUST IN OUR FIGHT AGAINST
INJUSTICE TODAY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIVEAU. SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
SENATORS- SPHERE OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I'M HONORED TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR TWENTY
NINE TO ESTABLISH CALIFORNIA'S
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY AND I
WANT TO THANK MY GOOD FRIEND
SINCE- SAN FRANCISCO FOR BRING
THIS FORWARD. THE HOLOCAUST
WAS- THE DARKEST LESSON OF THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY AND SHOULD
NEVER B FORGOTTEN THIS
RESOLUTION REMINDS US TO LEARN
FROM OUR HISTORY TO ENSURE THAT
THE HORRORS OF THE HOLOCAUST IS
NEVER ALLOWED TO HAPPEN AGAIN
AND UNFORTUNATELY IS MY GOOD
FRIEND THAT'S POINTED OUT TO ME
PEOPLE. DO NOT KNOW. THIS STORY
ALSO HIGHLIGHTS THOUGH THE HOPE
AND STRENGTH AND COURAGE AS
NEEDED FROM ALL OF US TO OPPOSE
INJUSTICE. THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
AND TE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
ATTORNEYS HAVE A LONG HISTORY
OF WORKING IN SOLIDARITY AND
SPEAKING OUT AGAIN IN THE FACE
OF BIGOTRY AND HATRED. DO AS
AMERICAN ORGANIZATIONS OF STOOD
WITH ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITIES TO EDUCATE
FUTURE AND THAT FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF THEINJUSTICES
OF THE JAPANESE AND AMERICAN
INTERNET. TO HELP COMBATANTI
MUSLIM POLICIES THAT SUPPORT
OUR COMMUNITIES AS WE FACE FACE
ARISE AND HATE INCIDENTS. THESE
ARE JUST A FEW OF MANY EXAMPLES
WE MUST STAND UNITED ACROSS ALL
FAITHS AND BACKGROUNDS AND WORK
TOGETHER BY SPEAKING OUT FOR
PEACE. NOW HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS
TEACH US IT STARTED WITH WORDS.
IT STARTED WITH WORDS DOES THAT
MEAN THAT WE THE PEOPLE. MUST
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE ORGANIZATIONS
AND CORPORATIONS TO PERMIT TO
FLORES. I WOULD LIKE TO
CONCLUDE WITH THE WITH A QUOTE
FROM A HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR- ILLY
ZELL HE SAID. PERMISSION TO
READ. PROVED YES WE MUST ALWAYS
TAKE SIDES. NEUTRALITY HELPS
THE OPPRESSOR NEVER THE VICTIM
SILENCE ENCOURAGES THE
TORMENTOR NEVER THE TORMENTED.
SOMETIMES WE MUST INTERFERE
ESPECIALLY ASKS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A C. R. TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
C. R. TWENTY NINE. ON BEHALF OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN AS A
MEMBER OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS.
THIS IS MORE THAN JUST A DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE A DAY IN HISTORY.
WHAT THE HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE
DAY IS ASKING US TO DO IS TO
PUT OURSELVES IN THE SHOES OF
THE JEWISH PEOPLE. THE JEWISH
PEOPLE WHO WORKS TRIPPED FROM
THEIR HUMANITY. ENTIRE FAMILIES
DESTROYED PEOPLE NOT KNOWING
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEIR LOVED
ONES. IT'S ABOUT ALLOWING
OURSELVES TO FEEL THE AGONY. OF
THE PEOPLE WHO FROM ONE DAY TO
THE NEXT WERE PLUCKED FROM
SOCIETY HUMILIATED STARVED
BEATEN. DEHUMANIZED THEIR NAMES
STRAIGHT AND WITHOUT MERCY
EXECUTED. JUST BECAUSE THEY
WERE JEWISH. THE WOMEN
EXPERIENCES PARTICULARLY VERY
PAINFUL FOR ME AND I'M SURE
MANY OF MY FEMALE COLLEAGUES. I
IMAGINE COUNTLESS MOTHERS BEING
SEPARATED FROM THEIR CHILDREN.
MANY OF THEM JUST INSTANCE
BEYOND HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
THEIR OWN WELL BEING HAVING TO
WORRY WHERE THEIR CHILDREN
WERE. ARE THEY CRYING BY THE
FED IS SOMEONE HURTING THEM.
AND EVEN WORSE JUST WARNING
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THEY CANNOT
KEEP THEM SAFE. THEY HAVE TO
HAVE EXPERIENCED DESPERATION.
WONDERING IF THEY WERE GONNA
MAKE IT THROUGH THAT THEY WOULD
EVER SEE THEIR CHILDREN AGAIN.
AS A TEACHER I HAD LESSON PLANS
THAT REQUIRED MY STUDENTS TO DO
SOME RESEARCH ON THE HOLOCAUST.
ONE OF THE ITEMS THAT THEY
WOULD ALWAYS FIND WAS EXTENSIVE
RECORDS. OF DIARIES AND NOTES
FROM CHILDREN. AND THE CURRENT
TEAM AND THESE DIARIES. WAS A
YEARNING FOR EDUCATION TO COME
BACK TO SCHOOL AND TO JUST FEEL
THE SENSE OF NORMALCY THAT THEY
ONCE HAD. IN THE LAST YEAR WE
HAVE SEEN HOW DISTRAUGHT OUR
CHILDREN OUR FAMILIES AND EVEN
OURSELVES HAVE BEEN WITH THE
PANDEMIC. NOW IMAGINE FOR US IT
WAS JUST ONE YEAR. SAFE IN OUR
HOMES FORTY FAMILIES THE LIVING
CONDITIONS WERE HORRIFIC AND
THE AGONY AND THE PAIN. AND
IMAGINABLE. YET WE HAVE IN THE
PAST. AS A NATION ALLOW
TRANSGRESSIONS AGAINST SPECIFIC
GROUPS. AND THE KERN RICE OF
HATE AND MISINFORMATION IN OUR
SOCIETY AND MOST RECENTLY
AGAINST OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS AND THE API COMMUNITY
REMINDS US THAT WE HAVE TO BE
VIGILANT. WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS WAS NOT AN
ACCIDENT. IT WAS PEOPLE ACTING
ON I. DS AND HATEFUL RHETORIC
LEADING THEM TO ULTIMATELY DO
HUMAN NICE. OTHER HUMAN BEINGS.
THAT'S WHY THIS RESOLUTION IS
SO IMPORTANT. TO REMIND US THAT
WE ARE ONLY HUMAN AND THAT WE
HAVE TO CONCOCT DAILY WORK AT
KEEPING OURSELVES FROM ACTING
ON OUR WORSE IMPULSES EVERY DAY
WE HAVE TO WORK TOWARDS A
BETTER COUNTRY. AND A BETTER
WORLD AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR I. POLITICI THANK YOU.
SENATOR DRAWS A. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. I RISE IN- SUPPORT
MY HONORED TO SUPPORT S. C. R.
TWENTY NINE AND ALSO IN HONOR
MARIA SCHENKER. A POLISH JEW
WHO DIED IN THE CAMP ON AUGUST
NINETEENTH NINETEEN FORTY TWO.
AS PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THE
RESOLUTION I FEEL THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT WE LEARNED THAT
KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTAND THE
FULL HISTORY OF THESE
TRANSFORMATIVE EVENTS THE
CHANGE THE COURSE OF THE WORLD
AND OUR LIVES. THE GRAVITY IN
THE IMPACT OF THE ATROCITIES
THAT OCCURRED DURING THE WHOLE
COSTS. ARE IMMENSE. SIX MILLION
JEWS AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION
OTHER PEOPLE WHO THE GERMANS
FELT WERE RACIALLY INFERIOR-
MURDERED BY THE **** GERMAN
DICTATORS AND IT WAS PART OF A
STATE SANCTIONED EFFORT. OF
CULTURAL SOCIAL AND POLITICAL
ANNIHILATION. LET US REMEMBER
AND EMPHASIZE THE ACTS OF
HEROISM LOVE AND EMPATHY THAT
ALSO OCCURRED AT THE TIME.
THERE ARE COUNTLESS STORIES OF
EVERYDAY HEROES WHO PUT THEIR
OWN LIVES ON THE LINE TO
PROTECT AND SAVE PEOPLE WHO
WERE IN LINE TO BE MURDERED
BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE RELIGION
OR OTHER DIFFERENCES. THERE'S A
VIRAL VIDEO OF A BRITISH
GENTLEMAN NAME SIR NICHOLAS
WINTON. BEEN SURPRISED AT AN
AMPHITHEATER NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT SURROUNDED BY STRANGERS
WHO ENDED UP BEING SOME OF THE
SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
CHILDREN HE HELP SAVE FIFTY
YEARS EARLIER FROM
CZECHOSLOVAKIA ON THE EVE OF
WORLD WAR TWO HE HELP SAVE
THESE CHILDREN FROM THE HORRORS
OF THE HOLOCAUST. THROUGH A
REFUGEE PROGRAM THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED TO HELP KIDS
YOUNGER THAN SEVENTEEN RELOCATE
IF THEY HAD A HOST FAMILY. HIS
EFFORTS INVOLVED DANGERS BRIBES
FORGERY SECRET CONTACTS NINE
REAL ROAD TRAINS AN AVALANCHE
OF PAPERWORK AND A LOT OF
MONEY. THE VIDEO IS
HEARTWARMING BECAUSE OF THE
APPRECIATION SHOWN NOT ONLY BY
SIR WIN BUT ALSO BY THE ADULTS
IN THE ROOM WHO WERE PROVIDED
AN OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE FULL
LIVES BECAUSE OF HIS HEROISM.
WE ALSO CAN'T FORGET HIS
ABILITY TO SAVE THE CHILDREN
ALSO INVOLVED HIM MEETING
TERRIFIED PARENTS WHO ARE
DESPERATE ENOUGH TO SAVE THEIR
CHILDREN THAT THEY SURRENDERED
THEM TO STRANGERS IN A FOREIGN
LAND THAT SOUND FAMILIAR. SAYS
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE JEWISH
COMMITTEE. WITH ALL THOSE WHO
SUFFERED GREATLY BECAUSE OF THE
HOLOCAUST AND ASK YOU ALL TO
REMEMBER THE PAST SO WE DON'T
REPEAT. ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS EXTEND OUR THANKS THE
JEWISH CAUCUS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND IMPORTANT WORK
ON THIS RESOLUTION. SENATOR MAN.
THE MAN CARE I'D LIKE TO
SINCERELY THANK MY COLLEAGUE
AND FRIEND FROM SAN FRANCISCO
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD- THE
CITY OBVIOUS THE HOLOCAUST IS
ONE OF THE WORST TRAGEDIES THIS
WAS EVER EXPERIENCE AN EXAMPLE.
OF THE DEPTHS TO WHICH THE
WHOLE HUMAN SOKEN SANK THE
EVILS OF WHICH THE HUMAN RACE
IS CAPABLE OF. THIS WAS A
SYSTEMATIC BUREAUCRATIC STATE
SPONSORED PERSECUTION AND
MURDER OF SIX MILLION JEWS. NOW
WE TALK ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST AND
SAY NEVER AGAIN BUT THAT HAS TO
BE A ACTIVE. TERM WE HAVE TO BE
ACTIVE IN MAKING SURE THAT THIS
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN AND HONOR
THE HOLOCAUST AND THE VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS OF THAT WE HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE THE FRAGILITY OF
OUR OWN CIVILIZATION OF OUR OWN
SOCIETY CULTURE. AND
INSTITUTION AGAINST ON
TRACTATE. OVER SEVENTY YEARS
AFTER THE HOLOCAUST WE ARE AS
OTHERS HAVE MENTIONED IN DANGER
OF FORGETTING THE LESSONS OF
THE HOLOCAUST. WE ARE SEEING
RIGHT NOW AN ALARMING RISE IN
HATE OF ALL STRIPES INCLUDING
AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS IN MY
DISTRICT WE SAW THE HORRIFIC
MURDER OF BLAZE BERNSTEIN. AND
OPENLY GAY AND JEWISH YOUNG MAN
IN ORANGE COUNTY BY MEMBER OF
AN ANTI SEMITIC AND HOMOPHOBIC
HATE GROUP. WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER
OF ANTI API ACTS OF HATE AND
JUST LAST WEEK IN MY DISTRICT
WHO CLOCKS PLAN PROPAGANDA WAS
DISTRIBUTED. IN NEWPORT BEACH
AND HUNTINGTON BEACH IN MY
DISTRICT THEY'RE PLANNING A
WHITE LIVES MATTER RALLY IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH IN THE COMING
DAYS. THE RISE OF HATE IS ON
THE MARCH AND AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS WE HAVE TO STAY
VIGILANT AND CALL THIS OUT WHEN
WE SEE IT. SO THAT IT NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN. WE NEED TO STAND
UNITED WITH OUR MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITY AND AS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY CONTINUE TO CONDEMN HATE.
DISCRIMINATION AND BIGOTRY IN
THE STRONGEST POSSIBLE WAY. I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE IN SOME
SENSES SCHOOL AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR ITEM. SENATOR ALAN.
ISN'T- PLANNING ON SPEAKING
TODAY BUT- BUT I WAS REALLY
STRUCK BY THIS CONVERSATION
WE'RE HAVING ABOUT. ROSS
COMMUNITY SOLIDARITY AND THE
TWEET THAT- THAT. I'VE BEEN
GIVEN FOR MY BIRTHDAY MARCH
THIRTEENTH AND I WAS STRUCK BY
THE FACT THAT. YOU'RE NOTICING
YOUR BOOKLETS AND MOST OF THE
VICTIMS THAT ARE HIGHLIGHTED.
WE'RE IN THE JEWISH BUT THE ONE
THAT WAS HIGHLIGHTED FOR ME.
WAS A POLISH SILESIAN CATHOLIC
PRIEST JOSEPH KOWALSKI. WHO IS
WHO WAS KILLED- IN HIS
THIRTIETH YEAR. THIS IS A- AND
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE GRAPHIC
NATURE OF THIS TWEET BUT I'M
WITH PERMISSION FROM THE FROM
THE CHAIR I'LL READ IT. HE WAS
KILLED ON JULY FOURTH. NINETEEN
FORTY TWO DROWNED IN A BARREL
OF FECAL MATTER IN THE PENAL
COMPANY. IN NOW STATES WHERE HE
WAS LACED FOR REFUSING. TO
TRAMPLE A ROSARY. NOW IF YOU
THINK ABOUT THIS MEMBERS THIS
WAS A MAN WHO WAS KILLED
PRESUMABLY BY BY SOMEONE WHO IT
WAS LIKELY RAISED IN THE
CHRISTIAN FAITH. I AND YET WHO
WHO HAD BECOME SO DEHUMANIZED.
BY HIS PARTICIPATION IN THE
HOLOCAUST HE WAS WILLING TO
WITNESS A MANIFEST A CATHOLIC
PRIEST DROWNED IN THIS AWFUL
MANNER FOR REFUSING TO VIOLATE
HIS OWN FATE BY TRAMPLING
ROSARY. REMIND ME SO MUCH OF MY
EXPERIENCE I SPENT SOME TIME
WORKING AT THE INTERNATIONAL
CRIMINAL TRIBUNAL FOR RWANDA IN
AFRICA AND I AND I'LL NEVER
FORGET A LINE I READ DURING
THAT EXPERIENCE- WHO IS A IS AN
INCREDIBLE BOOK CALLED MACHETE
SEASON WHICH TALKS ABOUT. THE
FOLKS WHO WENT OUT EVERY DAY TO
KILL PEOPLE DURING THE GENOCIDE
IN RWANDA. AND ONE OF THE
QUOTES ON NEVER FORGET WAS FROM
SOMEBODY WHO WAS A KILLER. WHO
BENEFIT ARMOR AND HE SAID- IT
WAS A LOT MORE FUN THAN FARMING
AND THAT HE REALIZED HE WAS A
LOT EASIER TO KILL A HUMAN
BEING IN THE TELECAST- AND HE
JUST WOULD GO OUT DAY AFTER DAY
WITH A MACHETE. AND STRAIGHT
DOWN. TOOTSIES AS PART OF THAT
GENOCIDE AND FOR ME IT JUST
REMINDS IT'S JUST A REMINDER OF
THE MULTIPLE LAYERS OF TRAGEDY.
THEY PLAY HERE THE
DEHUMANISATION IT HAPPENS TO
EVERYBODY INCLUDING THE FOLKS.
WHO PARTICIPATE IN THESE IN
THESE TERRIBLE ATROCITIES AND I
THINK IT'S A REMINDER ALSO OF
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR US.
TO NOT JUST THINK ABOUT THIS IS
A TRAGEDY THAT HAPPENED TO THE
JEWISH PEOPLE INDEED HAPPEN TO
SO MANY PEOPLE AND IT'S WHY
IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT THE
PERILS. OF WHEN WE WHEN WE
MARGINALIZE OTHER PEOPLE AND IT
REMINDS ME OF COURSE OF THIS
FAMOUS POEM FROM THE GERMAN
LUTHERAN PASTOR MARTIN NIEM
MAULER. THAT'S ABOUT THE
COWARDICE OF GERMAN
INTELLECTUALS IN CERTAIN CLERGY
INCLUDING BY HIS OWN ADMISSION
THE MILLER HIMSELF FOLLOWING
THE **** RISE TO POWER. IN
SUBSEQUENT INCREMENTAL PRGING
OF THEIR CHOSEN TARGETS GROUP
AFTER GROUP AFTER GROUP AND
SOME WITH PERMISSION TO READ. I
WILL READ HIS FAMOUS POEM.
FIRST CAME FOR THE SOCIALISTS
AND I DID NOT SPEAK OUT BECAUSE
I WAS NOT A SOCIALIST. THEN
THEY CAME FOR THE TRADE
UNIONISTS. AND I DID NOT SPEAK
OUT BECAUSE I WAS NOT A TRADE
UNIONIST AND OF COURSE WE CAN.
REPLACE THESE GROUPS WITH WITH
SO MANY- ON ON THE MARGINS THEN
THEY CAME FOR THE JEWS AND I
DID NOT SPEAK OUT BECAUSE I WAS
NOT A JEW. AND THEN THEY AME
FOR ME. AND THERE WAS NO ONE
LEFT TO SPEAK FOR ME. HIRED
YOUR VOTE YOUR SUPPORT FOR US
YOUR TWENTY NINE. SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AS CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF A C. R.
TWENTY NINE AS RELATES TO
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY. TODAY LET US
REMEMBER ALL THOSE THAT WE LOST
THE SOLDIERS WHO RISKED THEIR
LIVES TO LIBERATE TO
CONCENTRATION CAMPS. AND
SURVIVORS WHO MIRACULOUSLY
INVADED DEATH AND HOPELESSNESS
THAT SURROUNDED THEM. MORE THAN
SEVENTY YEARS OF PASS SINCE THE
HORRIFIC AND INHUMANE EVENTS.
OF THE HOLOCAUST IN WHICH SIX
MILLION JEWS FACED SYSTEMATIC
PERSECUTION AND DEATH AT THE
HANDS OF THE **** REGIME AND
THE CO CONSPIRATORS. THOUGH THE
**** DIDN'T. NOT ATTEMPT TO
ORGANIZE A STATE SANCTIONED
ELIMINATION OF BLOCKS. MANY
BLOCKS FACE THE PERSECUTION THE
ALIENATION AND THE MURDER OF
THE **** PARTY IN GERMANY BUT
GERMANS EXPERIENCED SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC ISOLATION BY WAY OF
DISCRIMINATORY POLICIES LIKE
THE NUREMBERG RACE LAWS OF
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE. WHICH
FORCED UPON- STERILIZATION OF
BIRATIONAL CHILDREN. BLOCKS
WERE NOT ONLY THE SOLELY
FASCINATION OF ADOLF HITLER-
DURING THAT BUT IT WAS THE-
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY FIRST. TAKE
A TARGET ALL AFRICAN AMERICAN
UNIT THEY WERE THE FIRST FACES.
THAT THE SURVIVORS OF THE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS SAW IT WAS
THOSE MEN WHO LIBERATED OUR
SHORTS AND THE FATHER
CONCENTRATION CAMPS DURING
WORLD WAR TWO YES THEY WENT
HOME HE FACED UNSPEAKABLE
PREJUDICE AND DISCRIMINATION
RIGHT HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY
SHOULD REMIND US ALL OF THE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF WHITE
SUPREMACY. AND IDEOLOGY AND THE
POLICE IT HAS GLOBALLY AND THE
FAX OF TRAVELING AROUND THE
WORLD WE- AS WE CONTINUE TO
WITNESS DRAMATIC RISE IN HATE
CRIMES AGAINST ALL HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED GROUPS. WE HAVE A
MORAL OBLIGATION TO SPEAK OUT
AGAINST. THESE INJUSTICES. IN
THE STATE THE LAST FOUR YEARS
THE FASCINATION AND CULT LIKE
FOLLOWING OF THE ORANGE MAN IS
JUST SAW IT ALL PHILLIP START.
AND IT CULMINATED IN THE SAME
WAY THAT WE SAW AT OUR NATION'S
CAPITAL ON JANUARY SIX THIS IS
JUST OF THE HOLOCAUST MOVEMENT
STARTED. SO AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE WEBSITE JUST STATED-
WE SHOULD BE MINDFUL OF THE
PAST MEMBERS LET'S NOT ONLY
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION TODAY WELL WE NEED
TO REALLY REMAIN VIGILANT AND
PERSISTENT AND FIGHT AGAINST
WHITE SUPREMACY BECAUSE IT'S
REAL IN THIS COUNTRY IT'S JUST
LIKE A WAS IN **** GERMANY.
SEVENTY YEARS AGO IT'S REAL AND
UNITED STATES IT'S IN THE DNA
OF THIS COUNTRY AND WE SHOULD
SPEAK OUT AGAINST IT OUR
STRONGEST IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE ASK FOR A VOTE.
SENATOR AKOWSKI. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AYE. AYE CHU WAS
NOT PLANNING TO SPEAK IN
BUT- AS A- PROUD. POLISH
CATHOLIC AMERICAN. AND SOMEBODY
WHO'S LIVED IN POLAND FOR TWO
YEARS I THOUGHT I'D- SHARE THE
BENEFIT OF MY THOUGHTS HAVING.
BEEN TO OCEAN ST WHICH IS A
SMALL TOWN THAT HOUSE WHICH WAS
RENAMED. THE GERMANS DID. CHOSE
OCEANS IN WHICH IS A SMALL
LITTLE- PLACE OUTSIDE OF A- I
KATOWICE BECAUSE IT'S WE'RE-
THE NORTH SOUTH. IN THE EAST
WEST RAIL ROAD CAME IN. AND
THAT. SMALL VILLAGE HAS WILL BE
CHANGED FOREVER BECAUSE MOST
PEOPLE WILL NEVER. HEAR THE
POLISH NAME AND KNOW. THE
TERROR THAT IT MAN. AND PEOPLE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT. YOU KNOW THE
STATISTICS THAT HAVE OCCURRED
OF YOU KNOW. IT'S COMMONLY
UNDERSTOOD OF THE SIX MILLION
JEWS THAT WERE KILLED. THREE
MILLION OF THOSE WERE POLISH
JEWS AND THREE MILLION MORE
JEWS FROM OTHER COUNTRIES.
ADDITIONALLY THERE WERE THREE
MILLION. POLISH CATHOLIC OR
POLISH ATS THAT WERE KILLED.
DURING THAT THAT TERROR WHEN I
STUDIED IT YEAH THE ONLY
UNIVERSITY. WHICH IS NAMED
AFTER KING YEAH GAIL. WHO IN
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO AFTER.
FERDINAND ISABEL KICKED ALL THE
JEWS OUT OF SPAIN INVITED THEM
TO SET UP THE CITY. IN POLAND
IT WASN'T THEIR FIRST CHOICE
AND I'M INTERESTED IN A LOT OF
PEOPLE FIRST CHOICE WOULD BE.
TO GO TO CRACK ALIBIED.
DEFENDER SAID THEY HAD. A PLACE
TO LIVE AND THEY WERE THE- IN
THE STATE THERE THEY WERE. OF
THE EARLY WERE THE TANKS FIRST
CAME IN AND THE POLISH ARMY WAS
FIGHTING AGAINST. THEM ON THEIR
HORSE BACKS AND THE RECEIVERS
THE FIRST THING THAT THEY DID
ON THE IN THE TERROR WITH THE
WOMEN AND KILLED ALL THE
MILITARY ALL THE LEADERS OF THE
MILITARY. AND THEN THEY WENT
INTO YAK ALONG KING INVERSELY
AND ILLED ALL THE PROFESSORS
FOR THE INTELLIGENCIA AND THE
POWER SYSTEM THAT WAS THERE
THERE WAS ELIMINATED. AND I'M
REFLECTIVE TODAY OF WHAT'S
GOING ON IN HUNGARY AND WHAT'S
GOING ON IN POLAND. WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT YOU HAVE THE
JUDICIARY IN THE EVEN NATION
BEING TORN APART. RIGHT NOW IN
PUTTING IN. REPRESSIVE FOLKS
BETTER. IN THE SAME TYPE OF
HORRIBLE RHETORIC THAT WE HEARD
FOR VOICE HEARD SEVENTY YEARS
AGO SO IT'S WITH GREAT SADNESS
THAT I SPEAK TO THE CHAMBER
TODAY BUT WITH WITH GREAT HOPE
THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM THE
LESSONS THAT WE DID THAT WE
CELEBRATE. WHETHER IT'S THE.
THE BLACK CAUCUS FOR THE ASIAN
PACIFIC CAUCUS TO THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS OUR DIFFERENCES BUT WE
UNITE TOGETHER AS CALIFORNIANS
HIS PEOPLE IN THE WORLD BODY TO
MAKE THINGS A LITTLE BIT THEIR
LIPS A LITTLE BIT BETTER FOR
THE NEXT GENERATION THAT'S
COMING. AND ORIGINAL BOX.
SENATOR STERN. PRESIDENT OF THE
THREE THE SOLIDARITY. I'VE
ALWAYS FROM CHAMBERS I THINK
SAYS MORE THAN I DO ABOUT. HE
NICK SINGULARITY OF THIS EVENT
THEY WERE COMMEMORATING TODAY I
THINK THE SINGULARITY OF OTHER
ATROCITIES AND HOW EACH ONE OF
THEM IS SORT OF UNIMAGINABLE ON
THEIR OWN- NEED EIGHT ALMOST
WHEN YOU HEAR THE WORD SIX
MILLION AND IT STOPS TO FEEL
REAL- MUCH LIKE. SOMETHING LIKE
INSULATING MILLIONS OF AFRICANS
AND BRINGING THEM OVER TO THIS
COUNTRY SEEMS KIND OF BEYOND
COMPREHENSION OR THE GENOCIDE
OF. MILLIONS OF NATIVE
AMERICANS DOESN'T REALLY FEEL
LIKE IT'S REAL BUT ALL THOSE
THINGS HAPPENED. I'M BUT JUST
LIKE THAT THOSE EVENTS IN
TRAGEDIES ARE UNIQUELY SINGULAR
SO WE'RE THE TRIUMPHS. AND
THOSE TRIBES ARE LONELIER
SOMETIMES. AND I WANTED TO JUST
SHARE ONE BRIEF TRIUMPH THAT I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF BECOMING
PRIVY TO MY OWN LIFE- MY FATHER
IN LAW AND MOTHER IN LAW
SURVIVED THE HOLOCAUST. JOSHUA
KAUFMAN- AT THE LAST TIME WE
HAD A HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL EVENT
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. STOOD ON
THE FLOOR WITH HIM- AND WITH
HIS DAUGHTER. IS NOW MY WIFE.
AND LEARNING FROM JOSHUA
MARGARET KAUFMAN TO IMMIGRANTS
TO THE UNITED STATES CAME OVER.
AFTER THEIR FAMILIES WERE
KILLED AND THEY DID NOTHING
LAST. AND TRYING TO REBUILD
SOME LIFE IN AMERICA. MOVING TO
LOS ANGELES AND IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AFTER SPENDING SOME
YEARS IN ISRAEL AND IN DP CAMPS
AND TRYING TO GO BACK TO HUNGRY
AND BEING PUSHED OUT BY THE
SAME ANTI SEMITES TO TURN THEM
OVER THE **** BUT WATCHING THEM
JUST MAKE A LIFE. IN LOS
ANGELES WORKING CLASS PLUMBER-
STILL HAS HIS PLUMBING TRUCK.
JOSH WAS PLANNING- FOR BUYING
PROBABLY AROUND THE WEST SIDE
OF LOS ANGELES IF YOU EVER SEE
IT WAVES- THE NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT FORTY CON ONLINE VET. AND
HE DROVE THAT PROUDLY WITH
AMERICAN AND ISRAELI FLAGS ON
TOP AND- SHOWED HIS PRIDE IN
BEING AN AMERICAN AND TO THE
SENATOR FROM GUARDINO IS POINT.
ABOUT THE VETERANS WHO
LIBERATED HIM HE HE DID LOSE
FAITH IN GOD. HE GREW UP- AN
ORTHODOX JEW IN DEBRECEN
HUNGARY IN AND HIS RABBI AND
SAID TO THE FAMILY JUST PRAY.
AND STAY THE RABBI LEFT AND
THEY DID STAY AND PRAYED AND IT
DIDN'T WORK. THEY LEFT IN
BEHIND BUT THE PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T DIDN'T SHOW UP AND
ACTUALLY LIBERATE THEM AND THE
PEOPLE HE SOUGHT OUT TO ANSWER
PRECISELY. THE AMERICAN
VETERANS WHO CENTER FROM
GUARDINO SPOKE OF. AND HE HAS A
DANGEROUS NOW TRADITION OF
KISSING THE SHOES OF ANY
VETERAN HE MEETS SO BE CAREFUL-
TO THE SENATOR FROM- A LITTLE
FURTHER SOUTH- IN PICO RIVERA
IF HE MEETS YOU YOU MAY KISS
YOUR SHOES I KNOW THERE WILL
SIGNED- BUT I JUST. WANT TO
TELL THAT STORY BRIEFLY BECAUSE
HE'S STILL HERE- HE'S IN A
HOSPITAL RIGHT NOW TRYING TO
RECOVER AND GET HIS FEET BACK
UP HONORING AGAIN BUT YOU
SHOULD KNOW THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE AMONG US WHO
HAVE SEEN THIS I HAVE BEEN HERE
TO THIS TRAGEDY. AND THEY'RE
STILL LIVING. AND THEY'RE PROUD
TO BE AMERICANS AND- THEY
GRANTED OUT JUST LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE SO LET'S USE THESE MOMENTS
AND NOT JUST SAY NEVER AGAIN-
BUT TO THE SENATOR OF IRVINE'S
POINT AS WE COMMIT OURSELVES TO
THE ACTION HERE. AND SO I'M
TRYING TO SEND JOSH WOULD
DOWNTURN THAT KKK RALLY-
BECAUSE I KNOW HE HAS A SIGN HE
LIKES TO BRING OUT ALL THE
HATEFUL RALLIES THAT HE SHOWED
UP AT OVER THE YEARS. THAT
SAYS- HE CALLS IT HATE MISS.
PLEASE YOU MUST FIGHT. HATE S.
pKAUFMAN I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
SENATOR KAMLAGER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I TOO WAS NOT
PLANNING TO SPEAK BUT WAS
TOUCHED BY SO MANY OF THE-
COMMENTS AN OBSERVATION SHARED
BY MY COLLEAGUES. YOM HA SHOAH
IS A DAY OF REMEMBRANCE WHERE
WE CAN HONOR THE MEMORY OF THE
MILLIONS MURDERED IN THE ****
HOLOCAUST. AND IT ALLOWS US TO
RE EXAMINE. OUR CONNECTED
HERITAGE TO LEARN MORE ABOUT IN
A KNOWLEDGE OUR COLLECTIVE
HISTORY. AND TO RECOMMIT TO
FIGHTING AGAINST HATE. BIGOTRY
AND INTOLERANCE. AS WAS
MENTIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GARDENA HITLER WAS EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY IN HIS SAVAGE
DISPLAY OF INHUMANITY HEALING
TO. JEWISH AND BLACK PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND WHILE NOT TARGETED
IN THE SAME PERNICIOUS WAYS.
MANY AS WAS MENTIONED WERE
STERILIZED INCARCERATED AND
MURDERED SHOWING HIS TRUE
DISDAIN FOR WHAT HE CALLED
RACIAL ALIENS. I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT ANTI SEMITISM IS STILL
REAL. AND IN X. INSIDIOUS
EXAMPLE OF HATE AND INTOLERANCE
HATE CRIMES ARE ON THE RISE IN
OUR JEWISH BROTHERS AND SISTERS
CONTINUE TO BE TARGETED. EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AND IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE HOLOCAUST CAN
HAPPEN AGAIN MAYBE WITH A
DIFFERENT WORD A DIFFERENT
TITLE. AND INSTEAD OF TRAINS
AND CAMPS AND SHOWERS. TODAY'S
TOOLS WOULD BE TECHNOLOGY AND
CLICKS. AND DATA MISINFORMATION.
BUT THE ONE ELEMENT THAT WOULD
REMAIN CONSTANT. IS FEAR. FEAR
OF ANOTHER FEAR OF ONE ANOTHER.
FEAR OF SOMEONE ELSE. I ASK
THAT WE CONTINUE TO. ACTIVATE
THE WORD SOLIDARITY AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT TRULY MEANS
TO LINK ARMS. WITH OUR BROTHERS
AND OUR SISTERS TO FIGHT
AGAINST THIS PERNICIOUS WEED
CALLED HATE AND ON BEHALF OF
THE SO MANY JEWISH AMERICANS
WITH WHOM I REPRESENT IN SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTY. I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AS C. R. TWENTY
NINE. SENATOR BURGESS. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. I THINK A
LOT HAS BEEN SAID TODAY. SOME
VERY TOUCHING STORIES. IN A FEW
WEEKS WE'RE GOING TO BE-
COMMEMORATING THE ANNIVERSARY
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE APRIL
TWENTY FOUR THE REASON I BRING
THAT UP. IS BECAUSE NGUYEN
ATROCITIES WENT UNANSWERED. IT
FACILITATED INSPIRED. OTHERS TO
RE COMMIT ATROCITIES SUCH AS
THE ONES THAT WERE EXPERIENCE
DURING WORLD WAR TWO IN THE
HOLOCAUST. THERE WAS A FAMOUS
QUOTE BY ADOLF HITLER- AFTER
THE OTTOMAN TURKS HAD- KILLED
THE ARMENIANS AND THE GREEKS IN
THE ASSYRIANS TO THE TUNE OF
OVER A COUPLE OF MILLION PEOPLE.
WHO AFTER ALL REMEMBERS THE
ARMENIANS. THAT I THINK IS VERY
TELLING. THAT A STATEMENT BY A
MONSTER LIKE THE FORMER LEADER
OF GERMANY OF THE RIGHT. WOULD
USE THAT AS AN EXAMPLE IN
JUSTIFICATION THAT HE COULD
COMMIT SUCH ATROCITIES AND
NEVER BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEM. I THINK WHAT'S INSPIRING
NOT ONLY IS WE HONOR THOSE THAT
PERISHED DURING THE HOLOCAUST.
IS THAT WE ALSO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT WE- REMIND OURSELVES HOW
EASILY THESE THINGS CAN HAPPEN
AGAIN. AND HOW THEY HAVE IN THE
LAST SEVENTY YEARS IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE WORLD. YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
XINJIANG. CHINA IN THE
NORTHWESTERN PORTION AND THE
CCP'S POLICIES TOWARD THE WEEK
OR- AND THE DETENTION OF
MILLIONS OVER THERE IN THE FOR
STERILIZATIONS ELECTRONIC
SURVEILLANCE. THESE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING WHETHER MY COLLEAGUE
GO FROM DOWN SOUTH INDICATED
HELLO RWANDA OCCURRED AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN. SO I
THINK AS WE- TAKE A VOTE ON S.
YOUR TWENTY NINE. WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY NOT ONLY TO
HONOR THOSE WHO HAVE FALLEN
DURING THE HOLOCAUST. BUT TO
REMIND OURSELVES REGULARLY.
THAT WE MUST STEP UP. ENGAGE BE
VOCAL AND TAKE ACTION WHETHER
IT'S ON THE ISSUES OF XINJIANG
OR EASTERN EUROPE OR WHAT'S
HAPPENING STILL OTHER PARTS OF
THE WORLD. WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION AS AMERICANS AS
HUMANS. WE SEE THESE THINGS WE
CANNOT BE SILENT BECAUSE OUR
COLLEAGUE SAID EARLIER IF WE
DON'T AND WE'RE THE LAST VOICE
STANDING. THERE WILL BE NO ONE
STANDING UP FOR US. SENATOR
JONES. PRESIDENT MEMBERS I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE BRIEFLY THIS
MORNING- A DAY THAT- CHANGED MY
LIFE A LITTLE BIT- MY WIFE'S-
I'M SORRY MY MOTHER'S
GRANDPARENTS IMMIGRATED FROM
GERMANY IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
HUNDREDS. SO I ALWAYS THOUGHT I
WAS SENSITIVE AND KNOWLEDGEABLE
ON THE HOLOCAUST. ALWAYS TRYING
TO PAY ATTENTION TO THE LESSONS
THAT HAVE BEEN TAUGHT BY THAT.
BUT DOES BETTER THAT TEN YEARS
AGO MY WIFE AND I WERE VISITING
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY FAIR OR
THAT THE DEL MAR FAIR. ON A HOT
SUMMER DAY WITH OUR THREE KIDS.
AND WORK KIND OF JUST DOING
WHAT YOU DO IT AT THE COUNTY
FAIR WALKING THROUGH THE RIDES
AND- THE DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
ARE BEING SOLD IN THE
EXHIBITION HALLS. BUT WE CAME
ACROSS A CORNER OF THE OF THE
FAIR THAT- IS KIND OF OFF TO
THE SIDE AND- NOT VERY WELL
DISPLAYED. BUT IT WAS A
TRAVELING HOLOCAUST MUSEUM-
DISPLAY. AND I THOUGHT WELL YOU
KNOW ALL OF THAT I THINK I KNOW.
THAT HISTORY. HI SO I TOOK MY
WIFE AND MY KIDS THROUGH THAT
HISTORY THROUGH THAT SMALL
EXHIBIT WASN'T VERY BIG MAYBE
TEN PANELS- TEN FOOT BY TEN
FOOT IN DISPLAYING PHOTOS AND
ARTIFACTS AND- DIFFERENT THINGS
FROM THE HOLOCAUST. MY LIFE
CHANGED THAT DAY. WALKING
THROUGH THAT DISPLAY- TO SEE IN
PHOTOGRAPHS AND IN ARTIFACTS.
AND TO GAINES SOME SMALL ASIAN
YOU CAN'T REALLY EVER GAIN AN
APPRECIATION FOR THAT KIND OF
THING ABOUT LIVING THROUGH IT I
SUPPOSE- THE SYNAGOGUE OF THAT
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO MISSION IS AND HOW WE
CALIFORNIAN MY DISTRICT. AND
THE RESILIENCY OF THAT
CONGREGATION HAS AMAZING. AS
HAS WE'VE ALL SHARED THE
RESILIENCY OF THE JEWISH PEOPLE
IN AMERICA AND THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD. I WAS AMAZED US WHILE
WE'RE SITTING HERE TODAY I
LOOKED UP THE LOS ANGELES. ALL
COST MUSEUM AND ON THEIR
WEBSITE THEY HAVE A VIRTUAL
TOUR THANK YOU CAN SIGN UP FOR.
I'M GONNASIGN UP FOR ONE AND
I'M GONNA TAKE A VIRTUAL TOUR.
OF THE LOS ANGELES HOLOCAUST
MUSEUM. BECAUSE I'VE NEVER BEEN
THERE IS ON MY LIST OF PLACES
TO VISIT. BUT UNTIL WE CAN
VISIT IN PERSON I'M GOING TO DO
THE VIRTUAL TOUR. AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE ALL OF US. AT TO DO
THAT OURSELVES AND ENCOURAGE
OTHERS TO DO SO ALSO. I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND S. C. R.
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU. THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING
NINE SENATOR WIENER YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU FOR THE- REALLY BEAUTIFUL-
COMMENTS ON THIS IN THE
HOLOCAUST IS SOMETHING THAT AS
CARD- THE JEWISH COMMUNITY IN A
IN A PERMANENT WAY WHEN I THINK
BACK TO THE FRONT OF MY- FAMILY
ON BOTH SIDES FLOOD USED IN
EUROPE AND RUSSIA- IN THE EARLY
TWENTIETH CENTURY TO ESCAPE
VIOLENCE- AND HAD THEY NOT BEEN
ABLE TO FULLY- AND HAD.
AMERICAN IMMIGRATION POLICY NOT
ALLOW THEM TO ENTER THEY WOULD
HAVE PROBABLY BEEN
EXTERMINATED- IN THE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS AND I WOULD
NOT BE HERE TODAY I THINK THAT
IS PROBABLY TRUE OF FIVE MOST
OF HER A LARGE MAJORITY OF THE
MEMBERS. OF THE JURY OF THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS- AND
SO IT'S A SORT OF MAKES IT REAL
IN TERMS OF WHAT THIS DID NOT
ON A LOOKING AT THE- OF THE
TWEET OF FOR MY BIRTHDAY MAY
ELEVENTH- WHO IS A FRENCH
JEWISH BOY NAMES ON ALONG ON
YOUR CARD TO DO. WHO WAS BORN.
IN NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE IN
ALGERIA. AND IN NINETEEN FOUR.
SO HE WAS- EIGHT YEARS OLD- HE
WAS TRANSPORTED. TO
CONCENTRATION CAMP TALLIS
VOTES. AND HE WAS- EXTERMINATED
IN A GAS CHAMBER AT THE AGE OF
EIGHT YEARS OLD. WITH FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE OTHER
PEOPLE- THE HORROR OF THE
HOLOCAUST IT'S- AND CENTER AS A
SENATOR. FROM LOS ANGELES
STATED IT'S ALMOST TWO. LARGE
AND SIGNIFICANT TO GET YOUR
HEAD AROUND- AND THAT'S WHY FOR
SO MANY PEOPLE TODAY IT'S FADED
AND IT GETS DISMISSED PURPOSES
TO PAY THAT COULD NEVER
POSSIBLY HAVE HAPPENED- AND
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE
SURE TH PEOPLE NEVER FORGET.
THAT IS NEVER EVER EVER HAPPENS
AGAIN- PRESENT PLANS FOR AN IPO.
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION NINE FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE FIVE
ITEMS IS THERE ANY MEMBER THAT
WOULD LIKE AN ITEM POOL FOR
SEPARATE DISCUSSION. SEEING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILLS.
431-400-5786 THIRTY FOUR AND
SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVENTEEN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
SEVENTY FIVE. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS HI BATES.
HI BAKER. I PORCHES FIVE
BRADFORD HI CABRERO HI
PROTESTING I DALY. FIVE DODD HI
DURAZO'S HI EGGMAN I GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ HI GROSS. HI HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO I JONES
HI KAMLAGER HI LAYERED HI LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ. HI MEN
HI NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. HI A
TELEPHOTO I PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
NUMBER FIVE WHAT CASTING I
WIENER HI WILK. PRICE THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO ON ITEM.
SEVENTY FIVE FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATOR SKINNER FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE. UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU MEMBERS
I MOVE THE ADOPTION OF AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS FOR BUDGET BILLS
THAT CROSS THE DESK ON FRIDAY
SATURDAY AND SUNDAY APRIL NINTH
TENTH AND ELEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THESE AMENDMENTS
WILL BE ADOPTED PUBLISHED IN
THE MEASURES RETURNED TO
COMMITTEE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. CENTER NIELSEN. I RISE IN
ADDICTION ASK FOR A NO VOTE
THIS IS MORE OF THE HABIT OF
DOING THINGS ON THE WEEKEND
WHAT THE PUBLIC IS CUT OUT AND
THEY EVEN WE ARE TO. VIRGIN
MOBILE OKAY. THERE'S A MATTER
BEFORE THE- FLOOR CENTER
SKINNER AS FOR AN AYE VOTE
CENTER NIELSEN ASKED FOR NO
VOTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
HI BATES NO BACKER. FIVE FORTUS
NO BRADFORD HI BIODOME HI
CORTESE HI DALLY NO DODD I TO
RAZA HI EGGMAN. GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO HI
FURTADO'S HI JONES NO KAMLAGER.
I LAYERED I LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE.
HI MELENDEZ NO MAN HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. NO- CHAU OF BOTH. NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. HI
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER HI NUMBER
FIVE CASKEY HI WIENER FIVE WELL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
EGGMAN HI WELL. HIS TWENTY NINE
KNOWS EIGHT THE MOTION PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS SAID THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WILL BE WILL
BEGIN AT ELEVEN AM IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. SENATOR RUBIO.
ATTY INSURANCE COMMITTEE WILL
MEET AFTER WE ADJOURNING GIVEN
ENOUGH TIME TO CLEAN THE
CHAMBERS AND IT WILL BE
ANNOUNCED ON THE-
TELECONFERENCE THANK YOU- GOOD.
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MEMBER WE'RE GOING
TO MEMBERS ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
THE ADJOURN AND MEMORIES
SENATOR ATKINS. WHEN PRESIDENT
THANK YOU AND I WOULD ASK- FOR
THE INTELLIGENCE OF MY
COLLEAGUES- ESPECIALLY TODAY
GIVEN THAT THE ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY IS OF FORMER SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE A JIM
MILLS. AND I'M GOING TO BREAK A
LITTLE BIT FROM PRACTICE
BECAUSE I'M SURROUNDED BY THIS
GLASS AND I'M THE LAST PERSON
AT THIS MIKE AND I'M GONNA TAKE
MY MASK OFF. I RISE TODAY TO
HONOR THE LIFE OF SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE REGION
MILLS WHO PASSED AWAY LAST WEEK
AT THE AGE OF NINETY THREE. AND
I'M PARTICULARLY HONORED THAT
ARE I'M GOING TO BE JOINED IN
DISCUSSION OF THIS ADJOURNMENT
BY THE DEAN OF OUR SENATE. I
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM TO HEMA
AND FROM OUR MAJORITY LEADER.
NOW BOTH OF THEM OF COURSE I
HAVE ACTUAL. STORIES AND LIFE
EXPERIENCES WITH SENATOR MILLS.
I HOWEVER I DON'T HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING HIM AS AS
WELL AS IS THEY DID- ALTHOUGH
FROM SAN DIEGO AND MOST OF YOU
KNOW THAT JIM MILLS WAS THE
SECOND- PRO TEMPORE A FROM SAN
DIEGO I AM THE THIRD. BUT I
CAME UP UNDER MY MENTOR AND
PREDECESSOR SENATOR KIKO- AND
WITH THE KNOWLEDGE FROM MY DEAR
FRIEND. A LOBBYIST CONSULTANT
BEEN CLAY I GOT TO HEAR GREAT
STORIES ABOUT JIM MILLS I WAS
IN AWE OF HIM AND WHILE WE WERE
IN TOWN AT THE SAME TIME. I
GOTTA BE HONEST I WAS A LITTLE
BIT INTIMIDATED TO APPROACH
THIS ICONIC MAN WHILE HE WAS A
QUIET IN NATURE AND STATURE. I
CONSIDERED HIM A GIANT AND HE
WAS HISTORIC IN SAN DIEGO FOR
THE THINGS THAT HE ACCOMPLISHED
WHICH I WILL. LEAD THE WAY IN
MENTION IN A MOMENT- YOU KNOW
THOSE OF US FROM SAN DIEGO IN
SOME OTHER COUNTIES. NOT LA OR
SAN FRANCISCO HISTORICALLY NO-
THAT A LOT OF THE LEADERSHIP
HAS COME FROM- THE GREAT CITIES
OF LA AND SAN FRANCISCO SO
WHEN. A SMALL TOWN WHICH IS HOW
I LEARNED OF SAN DIEGO GROWING
UP IN SOUTHWEST VIRGINIA. MY
DAD CALLED IT A SLEEPY LITTLE
TOWN WHEN HE SERVED HERE IN
WORLD WAR TWO. SO WHEN I MADE
MY WAY WEST SIDE TO SAN DIEGO A
GREAT CITY- I THOUGHT OF US AS
A SLEEPY LITTLE TOWN STILL EVEN
AS I BECAME A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER AND HEADED TO SACRAMENTO-
SO TO FOLLOW IN THE FOOTSTEPS
OF A GIANT LIKE. SENATOR MILLS.
IS A GREAT HONOR. AND I LOOK
FORWARD- TO THE STORIES- THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM MY
COLLEAGUES AS I WRAP UP I WILL
GIVE YOU. THE ITEMS THAT NEED
TO BE COVERED IN AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT AND THEN
ADJOURNMENT FOR A MAN. LIKE
SENATOR MILLS. KIM WAS A NATIVE
SAN DIEGANS EARNED HIS
BACHELOR'S AND MASTER'S DEGREES
IN HISTORY FROM SAN DIEGO STATE
GO AS TAX. AND WENT ON TO SERVE
OUR COUNTRY IN THE ARMY DURING
THE KOREAN WAR. AFTER HIS
SERVICE JIM RETURNED TO SAN
DIEGO AND TAUGHT MIDDLE SCHOOL.
AND RAN IT INTO PERO SERRA
MUSEUM. IN NINETEEN SIXTY WITH
ENCOURAGEMENT FROM HIS WIFE
JOANNA. JIM WON AN ELECTION TO
THE STATE ASSEMBLY WHERE HE
SERVED FOR SIX YEARS BEFORE
RUNNING AND WINNING A SEAT IN
THE SENATE. WHERE HE SERVED
UNTIL NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO. HE
SPENT TWENTY TWO YEARS IN THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE
INCLUDING NEARLY A DECADE AS
PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE A FROM.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY. TIM'S LEGACY
AS A LEGISLATOR WILL BEST BE
REMEMBERED- BY MOST FOR HIS
FORWARD THINKING WORK ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND HISTORIC
PRESERVATION. HE AUTHORED A
BILL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
TO CREATE THE SAN DIEGO TROLLEY
SYSTEM THAT WOULD LATER BECOME
A MODEL FOR THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY. AND MUCH OF OUR
STATE'S HISTORY HAS BEEN
PRESERVED AS A RESULT OF THE
MILLS ACT WHICH IS NAMED AFTER
HIM THE LAW HAS BEEN CREDITED
WITH SAVING THOUSANDS OF
HISTORIC BUILDINGS IN
CALIFORNIA. FROM DESTRUCTION
THE RIPRAP PRETTY TAX INCENTIVE
FOR OWNERS WHO PRESERVE THEM.
JAMES PIONEERING VISION ON THE
SAN DIEGO TROLLEY AND THE
PRESERVATION OF BUILDINGS LIKE
THOSE IN HISTORIC OLD TOWN SAN
DIEGO. BELIEVE IN ETERNAL
FOOTPRINT IN OUR COMMUNITY HE
ALSO. A STATUS THE LEGISLATION
THAT CREATED OUR PORT IN SAN
DIEGO. HOWEVER IT'S LESS
PUBLICIZED- UNLESS PUBLICIZED
ACTION THAT JIM TOOK THAT HAS
LEFT A LASTING INSPIRATION AN
IMPRESSION ON ME. OVER FORTY
YEARS AGO IN THIS CHAMBER THERE
WAS A DEBATE ON A BILL THAT
WOULD DECRIMINALIZE
HOMOSEXUALITY THE BILL WAS
PLACED ON CALL. ONE VOTE SHORT
IN A TWENTY TWENTY TIE. FORMER
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR MERVYN
DONNELLY WAS IN COLORADO AT THE
TIME AS YOU KNOW IN INSTANCES
OF A TIE VOTE OR MAYBE WE
HAVEN'T EXPERIENCED THIS SO WE
DON'T EXACTLY REMEMBER IT ALL
BUT IN THOSE INSTANCES IT IS
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WHO
SERVES AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SENATE WHO CAST THE DECIDING
VOTE. INSTEAD OF ADJOURNING THE
SESSION SENATOR MILLS DECIDED
TO KEEP THE BILL ON CALL UNTIL
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR'S VOTE
COULD BE CAST HOURS LATER. AND
HE KEPT HIS FELLOW SENATORS IN
PLACE SO AS TO HOLD A QUORUM
AND WE ALL KNOW WHAT THAT FEELS
LIKE TO BE HELD IN PLACE. WHEN
PRO TEM JIM MILLS TEMPORARILY
LOCKED THE SENATE DOORS HE
HELPED COUNTLESS CALIFORNIANS
PERMANENTLY OPEN THEIR CLOSET
DOORS. AND TAKE A GIANT STEP
TOWARDS EQUALITY. AFTER HIS
TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE JIM
SERVED ON THE SAN DIEGO
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
DEVELOPMENT BOARD WHICH I NAMED
ITS HEADQUARTERS AFTER HIM I
SPENT. A NUMBER OF YEARS ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM C. N. T.
SERVING ON THAT BOARD OF THAT
BUILDING THAT BEARS HIS NAME.
HE SPENT TIME ON AMTRAK'S BOARD
AND THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY. JIM IS SURVIVED
BY HIS THREE CHILDREN BEATRICE
ELEANOR AND BILL AND NINE
GRANDCHILDREN IT WAS REALLY AN
HONOR- IT TO SEE HIM RECOGNIZED
AND I WANT TO THANK- THE
INDIVIDUAL WAS TRYING SO HARD
THIS MORNING TO REMEMBER THE
PERSON THAT GAVE ME SO THAT I
WOULD LEARN. A LITTLE MORE OF
THE HISTORY A COPY OF JIM'S
BOOK- A DISORDERLY HOUSE IT WAS
INTERESTING READING AND- I WILL
TURN IT OVER NOW WITH YOUR
PERMISSION- PRESIDENT- TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO ADD TO HIS
COLORFUL HISTORY AND STORY AND
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR THE
INDULGENCE. THIS IS PART OF OUR
HISTORY OUR LEGACY AND- WE
CANNOT LET THE MOMENT PASS
WITHOUT ACKNOWLEDGING A GREAT
MAN. THANK YOU. SENATOR NIELSEN.
BETTER PRESENT READY GENTLE OF
THE SENATE I'VE BEEN BLESSED TO
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO COME HERE
DURING THE TENURE OF SENATOR
JIM MILLS. AS A FRESHMAN
SENATOR. YOU REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE GETTING INTO AND
YOU NEED A LOT OF HELP AND
MENTORING JIM WAS GREAT AT THAT.
BUT THE THING THAT I WILL
REMEMBER HIM MOST FOR HIS
REVERENCE FOR HISTORY. AS
YOU'VE COME TO THIS THE SENATE
CHAMBER. HE COULD PASS IN YOUR
MIND BECAUSE- WHEN THIS CHAMBER
WAS DESIGNATED AS AS EARTHQUAKE
VULNERABLE. MUCH DEBATE WENT ON
IS WHAT DO WE DO. AND A COUNTER
PROPOSAL TO RESTORING THIS
BEAUTIFUL BUILDING WAS
TEREPHTHALIC AND BUILD TWIN
TOWERS. FORTUNATELY THAT DID
NOT PREVAIL ENGINE BEING
ASSISTED IS HISTORIAN INSISTED
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
RESTORE THIS CHAMBER. THERE
WERE CONCERNS THAT THERE WOULD
NOT BE. THE PEOPLE WHO COULD DO
THIS KIND OF WORK THE TECHNICAL
WORK. THE CAREFUL WOULD WORK
REQUIRED TO EMULATE THE CAPITAL.
THE ORIGINAL CAPITAL. AND I
HAVE A PICTURE OF THE REGIONAL
CAPITAL OF PAINTING PICTURE IN
MY OFFICE. JIM WAS INSISTENT
ABOUT THAT. AND THAT BEING THE
CASE THIS IS WHAT WE GET TO
ENJOY. I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW IT
WOULD BE DIFFERENT. TODAY AND
MORE FOR THE STERILE FACILITY
THEY MIGHT BE VERY NICE MAYBE
SOME MORE AMENITIES. BUT THIS
IS HISTORY. AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD ARGUE
THAT WE ALL OF PAYMENT MORE
ATTENTION TO. GEN BEING A
HISTORIAN AND A MAGNIFICENT
WRITER ABOUT HISTORY. DID CARE
ABOUT WHAT WENT ON HERE BEFORE.
WHEN I CAME BACK AFTER EIGHTEEN
YEARS HIATUS PEOPLE SAID JIM
WHAT'S DIFFERENT NOW THAN
BEFORE I SAID WELL.
COLLEGIALITY IS DIMINISHED
GOING FOR EACH OTHER. AND A
REVERENCE FOR THE PAST OR EVEN
A CURIOSITY ABOUT IT. HAS
DIMINISHED. AND THAT'S NOT
HELPFUL. SO AS WE ADDRESS BILLS.
DURING THIS YEAR OF FOR ME AT
LEAST IT IS VAN. MEMBERS COME
UP WITH LEGISLATION AND THAT
WAS THE BRIGHT LIGHT THAT WENT
ON AND THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE EVER TALKED ABOUT IT AND
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA. WELL
THERE'S VERY LITTLE NEW UNDER
THE SUN HERE. JIM KNEW THAT.
ANY GOOD COACH PEOPLE ABOUT
WELL WHAT WENT ON BEFORE SO
THEY MIGHT LEARN FROM THE
PRIOR. LEGISLATION THAT HAD
BEEN HERE. AND PARTICULARLY
KNOWING AND THE REFERENCE TO
THE RULES OF THE HOUSE OF THE
INSTITUTION. I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
IN THE MINORITY PARTY AROUND
HERE. WE GOT AS CLOSE AS
SIXTEEN ONE TIME. BUT I
REALIZED THAT THE PROTESTS.
THEY ALSO HAD. A SENSE OF THEIR
OWN HISTORY. THAT THEY WERE THE
PRO TEM. OF ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE. AND THIS
INSTITUTION IS ALWAYS HAD A
TRADITION OF BEING LESS
PARTNERS. IN ITS COMPARTMENT.
THEN THE STATE ASSEMBLY. KIM
WROTE SEVERAL BOOKS ONE ABOUT
PONTIUS PILOT. I WANT TO BACK
UP THE BOOK WAS OF PUNCHES
PILOT. ANOTHER WAS CALLED THE
DISORDERLY HOUSE. IT WAS KIND
OF A POKE AT THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
HE SPOKE ABOUT THE DIFFERENCES
OF THESE INSTITUTIONS. NOW I'VE
HAD THE PLEASURE OF SERVING IN
BOTH HOUSES OF BRIEFLY IN THE
ASSEMBLY IN A LONG TIME HERE.
AND THE TRADITIONS ARE
DIFFERENT. AND THE COMPORTMENT
IS DIFFERENT. ORDER THE SIMPLE
REASONS IS THERE MORE MEMBERS
OF THAT HOUSE THAN THIS ONE.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO TRADITIONS.
AND THERE ARE WORDS TO DESCRIBE
IT WORDS THAT DESCRIBE. SENATE
PRO TEM JIM MILLS SENATORIAL
COURTESY. HE WELCOME TO ME AS A
CALL. AS DID SOME OF THE OTHER
OLD TIMERS THAT EVEN PROCEEDED
JIM LIKE RALPH DEALS. I
APPRECIATED THAT AND IT'S
HELPED ME OVER THESE YEARS BE A
MUCH BETTER CENTER. THAN IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN. OTHERWISE HE
WAS A VERY AMIABLE MAN TO NOT
ABUSIVELY. MORE STATE. BUT YET
HE HAD A QUIET SENSE OF HUMOR
ABOUT IN. AND MOST OF ALL HE
HAD A REFERENCE FOR THIS
INSTITUTION. OFTEN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE I HAVE
WALKED DOWN THE HALLWAY HERE
AND- LOOK AT THE FORMER PRO
TENNIS. AND I'VE KNOWN PROGRAMS
ALL THE WAY BACK TO BUTCH
POWERS WHO'S IN A TENT GOVERNOR
UNDER A WARRANT. IT IS ALWAYS
STRUCK ME AS I LOOK AT THOSE
FORMER MEMBERS AND KNOW WHAT I
KNOW OF THEM HISTORICALLY IN
SOME CASES IT WAS EVEN
PERSONALLY. AND THEN WATCH THE
SUCCESSIVE PRO TEMS SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE. ALL OF THOSE FOR
TENS OF CARRIED ON THOSE
TRADITIONS. THE GYM HILLS SO
MARVELOUSLY UP HELPED. AND WHEN
WE COME HERE. WE NEED TO BE
REMEMBER REMEMBER THAT I THINK.
A FUNNY STORY. RALPH DEALS AND
I HAD AN INTERESTING HISTORY
AND WE CALL EACH OTHER BROTHER
DEALS AND BROTHER NIELSEN THAT
WAS MORE IMPORTANT THAN BEING A
CENTER BROTHER WAS A THE
BROTHERHOOD'S OF THE VARIOUS.
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WAS
IMPORTANT IN THE EAR OF
BROWNFIELDS NOT SO MUCH MY OWN
BUT THE ELKS CLUB THAT WOULD
MEAN THE WORLD. ORDER A LOT OF
FELLOWS OR WHATEVER. AND A
PERSON FROM THE ASSEMBLY CAME
AND JOINED THE SENATE. AND
WE'RE DOING THIS MARVELOUS
FEATURES REALLY STARTED UP AND
RAISING HIS VOICE AND WAVING
HIS HANDS AND. BY SEN ROGER
LETTERS DESK. IN ELECT YEP IT'S
RALPH GILLES TALL MAN POWERING
OVER ME. THEY LOOK DOWN AT ME
THEY SAID ARE YOU LISTENING TO
THE GOOD CENTER- I SHOULD I'M
LISTENING INTENTLY BROTHER
DEALS. WELL BROTHER NIELSEN.
DON'T YOU THINK WHEN HE
FINISHES WE SHOULD GO HAVE A
TALK WITH HIM. WELL THOSE ARE
CODE WORDS. CODE BEING WELL WE
BETTER JUST GUY SOMETHING. CODE
WORD WAS YOU GO FIRST AND ALL
BACKING UP. SO WHEN. THE GOOD
SENATOR SET DOWN I MOSTLY GO
OVER AND SAID WELL TO CENTER TO
HAVE A MARVELOUS SPEECH. I SAID
A FEW MORE THINGS I SAID OF THE
MARVELOUS SPEECH TO BE
DELIVERED. IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. AND THEN BROTHER
DEALS CAME YOU'RE A SENATOR AND
HE WAS A GREAT LESSON AND
SENATORIAL COURTESY. THAT
SENATOR NEVER HAD THAT A
PROBLEM AGAIN ALL THE
SUCCESSIVE PRO TENS. THAT I
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO THE PLEASURE
OF SERVING WITH HAVE COMPORTED
THEMSELVES AND STEWARDED THIS
INSTITUTION. IN THE MANNER THAT
JIM MILLS DID. MY SUMMATION IS
THIS WAS A MAN. OF THE PEOPLE
AND FOR THE PEOPLE. AND HE WAS
A MAN. OF THE SENATE. A GOOD
MAN. L. SURELY MISSION THEY
WILL JOURNAL MEMORY. A GREAT
LEADER CENTER JEN MILLS FOR TEN
OF THE STATE SENATE. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT IS- GREAT HONOR TO
JOIN WITH OUR PRO TEM AND DEAN
OF THE SENATE. IN ADJOURNING IN
THE MEMORY OF A FORMER PRO TEM
JIM MILLS. MY FIRST JOB IN THE
GOVERNMENT WAS WITH THIS BODY
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR AND MY
FIRST PAYCHECK AT FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH WAS SIGNED BY
JAMES R. MILLS CHAIRMAN OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE. IT WAS BIG
MONEY BACK THEN. AND- EARLY ON
AND GET TO KNOW HIM PERSONALLY
VERY WELL I JUST AS THE PRO TEM
SUGGESTED HER COPPER COMMENTS
WAS ALWAYS NERVOUS IN HIS
PRESENCE ALWAYS GRACIOUS TO ME
AS A YOUNG KID- NOT ONE OF
THESE TYPES OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
I TRIED TO- EXHORTED STORY BUT
ALWAYS LISTENED TO. YOU KNOW
JUST EXTRAORDINARILY KIND AND
GRACIOUS PERSON- I WAS THERE IS
AN EMPLOYEE OF MERV DONNELLY.
WORKING WITH HIM IN THIS THE
CALL CAME IN MERVIN WAS IN
CONTENT GOVERNOR SHOULDN'T SAY
MARTIN. WAS IN THE COLORADO AND
IT REALLY WAS AS THE PRO TEM
SUGGESTED. THE PROTON MILLS WHO
WAS THE LEADING FORCE BEHIND
THIS AND- GOT THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR TO COME BACK AND- YOU
KNOW I GONNA SAW SPACES I COULD
FROM A YOUNG ON TRAIN DIE- THE
POWER INFLUENCE AND COMMITMENT.
THAT HE EXPRESSED. I WASN'T IN
THE ROOM WHERE IT HAPPENED BUT
IT WAS NEXT TO IT AND I'VE GOT
TO OBSERVE IT TO SOME EXTENT.
HE CAME HERE IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SIX AFTER THE BAKER CARVE
DECISION RESULTED IN THIRTY
EIGHT MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
MOVING TO THE SENATE. GEORGE OF
MEIJIN WILSON ALL HOST OF FOLKS
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE IMPORTANT
LEADERS. IN THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA AND HE ROSE TO THE
HIGHEST LEVELS. HE WAS A CO
AUTHOR OF PROPOSITION ONE DAY
WITH JUST. THAT BROUGHT US TO A
FULL TIME LEGISLATURE IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX JOIN WITH
JESS IN THAT REGARD
TRANSFORMATIONAL ENDEAVOR. IN
THE BOOK THAT FOLKS TALK ABOUT
THE DISORDERLY HOUSE THAT I
HAVE A COPY HERE- HAVE A COPY
AT HOME BUT I WAS ABLE TO GET
IT IN TIME OUR GREAT INCREDIBLE
LIBRARIAN GREG LUCAS GAVE IT TO
ME. AN IMPORTANT POINT IS OUR
DEAN SAYS REVERENCE FOR HISTORY.
WE ALL LIVE IN THIS CHAMBER WE
ALL EXPERIENCE. THE KIND OF
HUMAN INTERACTIONS THAT RESULT
IN THE CREATION OF LEGISLATION
OR TAX QUIETLY PEOPLE ARE
ENGAGED IN THE HISTORIAN. WROTE
THIS BOOK TO TALK ABOUT THE
BROWN. THAT BROWN HENRI YEARS
THAT WERE TRANSFORMATIONAL IN
THE END WE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT AND
SO MANY THINGS THAT WE DID IN
CALIFORNIA TO CAPTURE THAT
HISTORY. UNFORTUNATELY YOU KNOW
UNLIKE THE FRAMERS OF OUR
CONSTITUTION OR OTHERS THERE
ARE NOT THAT MANY BOOKS TO
WILLIE BROWN BOOK FEW OTHER
BOOKS JOHN JACOBS WROTE THE
CAPTURE THE HISTORY. BUT I
THINK THAT THE POINT THAT THE
DEAN MADE ABOUT REFERENCE IS
INFORMED BY THE FACT THAT HE
TOOK THE TIME TO CAPTURE THAT
HISTORY AND I WOULD REALLY IT'S
AN INTERESTING READ SB SIX
THREE COMPLETE CANDID ABOUT A
DIFFERENT TIME IN HISTORY BUT
HE CAPTURES THAT MOMENT. AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT AND WE
RECENTLY COMMUNICATED WITH HIM-
AS THE PRO TEM- APPOINTED ME TO
REPRESENT THIS BODY ON THE
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY THIS
COMMITTEE THAT'S OVERSEEING THE
CAPITAL AND AS THE PRO TEM
INDICATED HIS REVERENCE FOR HIS
STATE HISTORIC BUILDINGS HE WAS
IN THE DISCUSSION WANTED TO BE
INVOLVED WITH RESPECTTO. THE
NEW CAPITAL AND WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE STILL IN THE GAME THE TIME
NINETY TWO YEARS OLD AGAIN
NINETY THREE WHEN HE PASSED
AWAY STILL IN THE GAME. STILL
HAVING THAT. HI PUBLIC SERVICE
DNA ABOUT STATE HISTORIC
BUILDINGS ABOUT THE VALUE OF
THE FUTURE IRRESPECTIVE OF HIS
AGE INFORMED BY HIS DEEP
COMMITMENT I ASK THAT WE
JOURNEY THIS MEMORY THANK YOU.
PLEASE MADAM PRO TEM. PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD TO THE
DEATH SO THAT THE SENATE CAN
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED HIM.
SENATOR MEN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO TURN IN
MEMORY OF LESLIE SONG WINNER- I
HAD THE CHANCE TO MEET ABOUT
TWO YEARS AGO AND IRVINE OVER
LUNCH WELL I DON'T KNOW HER AS
WELL AS MANY. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I COULD IMMEDIATELY
SEE WHAT A REMARKABLE KIND AND
PASSIONATE PERSON SHE WAS. WE
STAYED INSIDE TOUCH SINCE THEN
AND I WAS SO SADDENED TO LEARN
ABOUT HER DEATH LAST WEEK.
LESLIE PASSED AWAY ON APRIL
FIRST OF THIS YEAR PEACEFULLY
SURROUNDED BY LOVED ONES.
LESLIE WAS THE ELDEST CHILD OF
ALFRED SONG CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
ASIAN AMERICAN STATE LEGISLATOR
FIRST ELECTED TO THE ASSEMBLY
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE. AND THEN
ELECTED TO THIS BODY THE STATE
SENATE IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX.
WESLEY WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT
KEEPING HER FATHER'S MEMORY
ALIVE. AS DIRECTOR OF THE
SENATOR ALFORD AND SONG
COMMEMORATION COMMITTEE. SHE
LED THE INITIATIVE TO NAME THE
WILSHIRE MATCH WESTERN METRO
STATION AFTER HER FATHER. SO
IT'S WORTH BRIEFLY MENTIONING
HER FATHER'S CENTER ALFORD SONG
IN HIS REMARKABLE ACHIEVEMENTS.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW CENTER SONG
WAS A CREAM AMERICAN BORN AND
RAISED IN HAWAII. HE MOVED TO
LOS ANGELES IN NINETEEN FORTY
AND PERSEVERED AGAINST REPEATED
DISCRIMINATION THROUGHOUT HIS
LIFE. WHETHER ISN'T TRYING TO
ENLIST IN THE U. S. NAVY OR
PURCHASING A HOME WITH RACIAL
COVENANTS ON IT. AFTER THE SONG
WENT ON TO BREAK SO MANY BAMBOO
CEILINGS THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE A
GRADUATE OF USC'S COLLEGE AND
LAW SCHOOL. HE WAS THE FIRST
KOREAN AMERICAN ADMITTED TO THE
CALIFORNIASTATE BAR. THE FIRST
ASIAN AMERICAN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. AND SOMEONE WHO IS
SO FAR AHEAD OF HIS TIME IN
FIGHTING FOR THE RIGHTS OF
WORKING CALIFORNIANS. ANY PRESS
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER. AMONG
OTHER THINGS HE AUTHORED
GROUNDBREAKING LEGISLATION
PROTECTING VOTER RIGHTS. HE
CREATED THE OFFICE OF THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. OVERALL THE
CALIFORNIA EVIDENCE CODE AND
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAWS. THE SONG
BEVERLY CONSUMER WARRANTY ACT
ALSO KNOWN AS THE CALIFORNIA
LEMON LAW. UNTIL MY ELECTION
LAST YEAR CENTER SONG WAS THE
ONLY GREEN AMERICAN TO EVER
HAVE SERVED IN THIS BODY THE
STATE SENATE. AND HE LEAVES
HUGE SHOES TO FILL. IS A TRULY
EXCEPTIONAL LEGISLATOR WHO
SERVED HONORABLY HERE FOR
TWELVE YEARS. DESPITE HER MANY
YEARS OF ADVOCACY TO RECOGNIZE
THE ACHIEVEMENTS OF HER FATHER
LESLIE SONG WINNER. WAS NOT
JUST THE DAUGHTER OF ALFRED
SONG. SHE LIVED SUCH AN
INCREDIBLE LIFE OF HER OWN.
INSPIRED BY HER FATHER SHE
LIVED AND BREATHED POLITICS
WORKING IN THE GOVERNMENT AND
NONPROFITS IN THE NAME OF
PUBLIC SERVICE THROUGHOUT HER
CAREER. ADVOCATING FOR THINGS
LIKE MORE RECYCLING BETTER AIR
QUALITY IN RACIAL EQUITY.
LESLIE WAS FIERCE AND
UNAPOLOGETIC IN PURSUING
JUSTICE. SHE'S A PARTNER IN A
VERY SUCCESSFUL AND LUCRATIVE
POLITICAL CONSULTING FIRM
EARLIER IN HER CAREER BUT LEFT
AT THE HEIGHT OF EARNING POWER
STATING THIS IS NOT WHY I GOT
INTO POLITICS. AND LIKE HER
FATHER LESLIE WAS AHEAD OF HER
TIME IN THE FIGHT SHE CHOSE TO
PICK. AS A FIRE COMMISSION LOS
ANGELES IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
NINETY SHE BECAME EMBROILED IN
CONTROVERSY BECAUSE SHE
INSISTED ON STANDING UP FOR THE
RIGHTS OF MINORITY AND FMALE
FIREFIGHTERS. AT A TIME WHEN
THIS WAS ON POPULAR THING TO DO.
AS ONE COLLEAGUE OF HERS AT THE
TIME SAID. A SOMEWHAT
INTERESTING SHE'S VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT RACIAL JUSTICE
ISSUES. AND WILL FIGHT FOR THEM
SOMETIMES FOR OWN PERSONAL AND
POLITICAL DETRIMENT. I THINK
THAT'S A TESTAMENT TO HER
CHARACTER. LESLIE WAS A PROUD
KOREAN AMERICAN WHO IS DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GREEN COMMUNITY. SHE
HERSELF TAUGHT GREEN
IMMIGRATION HISTORY AND DONATED
A HUNDRED HISTORICAL ARTIFACTS
FROM THE FIRST SCREEN AMERICAN
SETTLERS TO THE CURRENT
GOVERNMENT. SHE IS THE FOUNDER
AND DIRECTOR OF THE KOREAN
VOTERS RESOURCE CENTER. AND SHE
STAYED ACTIVE IN RECENT YEARS
AT A TIME WHEN MANY WOULD BE
ENJOYING THEIR GOLDEN YEARS.
AND TWENTY NINETEEN SING THE
NEEDS OF THE ON HOUSE
POPULATION IN HER COMMUNITY HE
BEGAN DELIVERING HOME COOKED
MEALS TWICE A WEEK TO MACARTHUR
PARK IN LOS ANGELES. AS DEMAND
FOR THESE MEALS PICKED UP AND
GREW WITH THE RISE IN THE ON
HOUSE POPULATION LESLIE ROSE TO
MEET THE CHALLENGE. AS IT WAS A
PASSION FIRST TO HELP THOSE IN
NEED. SHE FOUNDED A NONPROFIT
CALLED LUNCH IN THE PARK TO
SCALE UP HER EFFORTS TO FEED
AND HOUSE WITH HOME COOKED
MEALS. AND EVEN TO THE END OF
HER LIFE SHE WAS CONTINUING TO
HELP OTHERS MULTIPLE TIMES A
WEEK IN PERSON. SHE IS SURVIVED
BY HER HUSBAND AND THREE
DAUGHTERS. AND I IT IS A VERY
SAD DAY WE'VE LOST A TRULY
GREAT AND GENEROUS LEADER.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND MADAM
PRESIDENT. PLEASE BRING IT THE
NAME FORWARD TO THE DEATH SO
THAT THE SENATE CAN
APPROPRIATELY MEMORY
MEMORIALIZE HER. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE AND TODAY I'M PRICE WITH
SADNESS TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
GIL CORDON FROM WEST COVINA
GAIL WAS BORN IN THE SAME YEAR-
VALLEY AND SERVED HER COMMUNITY
AS A TEACHER'S AIDE FOR FORTY
YEARS BOTH IN WEST COVINA
COVINA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. MRS GET TEN MARRIED
HER HER HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEART
PATRICK PORTENT AND THEY
DECIDED TO SETTLE IN WEST
COVINA TO RAISE THEIR TWO
CHILDREN. GAIL HAS HAD A TRUE
PASSION AND WORKING CLOSELY
WITH ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
CHILDREN. AND UP UNTIL HER
PASSING OF AGE EIGHTY FOUR WAS
ALWAYS VERY INVOLVED IN ALWAYS
OFFERED HOW. HER MARK IN LEGACY
IN THE COMMUNITY WILL SERVE FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME AS SHE
TAUGHT PARENTSTHEIR CHILDREN
AND EVEN THEIR GRANDCHILDREN.
THE DEDICATION TO EDUCATION
ALONG WITH HER COMPASSION AND
DEVOTION IS WHAT INSPIREDHER
OWN GRANDDAUGHTER TO BECOME A
TEACHER. GAIL IS SURVIVED BY
HER TWO CHILDREN SON MICHAEL
AND DAUGHTER JILL SHE IS ALSO
SURVIVED BY HER GRANDSON DANIEL
GRANDDAUGHTER JANE HER BROTHER
JACK AND SISTER JUDY AS WELL AS
MANY NIECES AND NEPHEWS GAIL
LEFT A LONG LASTING IMPACT IN
OUR LIVES AND WE WILL SURELY
MISTER. THANK YOU. PLEASE BEING
BRING HER NAME FORWARD TO THE
DESK SO THAT THE SENATE CAN
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED HER.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR BATES THE
DALLAS IS CLEAR. THANK YOU
MADAM OUR PRESIDENT OF THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY
AT TWO PM IN THE MEANTIME HAVE
A GREAT WEEKEND AND STAY SAFE.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE MADE WE WILL RECONVENE
ON MONDAY AT TWO PM. HAVE A
GREAT WEEKEND EVERYBODY.